When an anomaly is first detected by an SCP
Foundation Field Agent,
it’s up to the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces to tag and bag the impossible
entities before they can do any more harm.
Sometimes these retrievals are uneventful,
other times... not so much - especially when
they’re dealing with brutal forces of nature
like SCP - 096, also known as, The Shy Guy.
A creature that, from its very first interaction
with the Foundation, had a reputation for
being dangerous and needed to be feared.
A series of vague sightings and mysterious
disappearances up in the frosty mountains
of the Yukon first sparked the Foundation’s
interest. When they were certain that they
had an anomaly on their hands, two retrieval
teams - Zulu 9-A and Zulu 9-B - were dispatched
to secure and contain the entity. Zulu 9-A
took the lead in a heavy duty chopper, equipped
with .50 caliber GAU-19 Heavy Machine-Guns
and carrying an AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher. They
were prepared for anything - or so they thought
- as they established a visual on SCP - 096
while two clicks away from the target.
They couldn’t get a clear line of sight
on the creature, but it appeared to be stationary,
docile, and was making no attempt to flee.
Piece of cake, right? Little did they know
that SCP - 096 was just looking away from
them. If it was facing towards them, it’d
be a whole different horror story, as Zulu
9-A were about to find out.
The team landed their helicopter next to the
creature and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked, in spite of the subzero
temperatures all around them. The creature
was unnaturally thin, as though it’d been
starved for weeks, with bone-white skin and
unnaturally long limbs. The team guessed that
the creature’s arms must have been at least
1.5 metres long, but its docile nature and
insubstantial body mass gave the impression
that it wouldn’t prove too difficult to
contain. That is, until they saw its face.
Zulu 9-A’s Captain was the lone survivor
of the incident, as he was lucky enough to
be looking away when the creature turned towards
his team. The rest of the squad ended up staring
eye to eye with SCP - 096, and from that moment
on it wasn’t docile anymore. The creature
began to whimper, then cry,
then sob uncontrollably
in a way that sounded eerily human. This sudden
change in temperament startled the rest of
Zulu 9-A and they opened fire on the creature.
Under the hail of gunfire, SCP - 096 entered
a murderous frenzy and began tearing into
the hapless squad of soldiers. While its flesh
and organs did seem to take damage as a result
of the barrage of .50 caliber rounds from
the helicopter mounted machine guns, its skeletal
structure remained intact and it continued
its onslaught, tearing the team limb from
limb even after they’d blown practically
all the flesh from the creature.
The AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher proved equally
ineffective at stopping SCP - 096 while it
was in attack mode, and it was only after
slaughtering the entire team that it returned
to its docile state. Nobody knows exactly
what the creature did to Zulu 9-A after the
gunfire started, but no trace of the team
was left behind.
Zulu 9-B touched down soon after, and with
a grave warning from the Captain not to look
at the creature’s face, they were finally
able to subdue it. A bag was placed over SCP
- 096’s face, which seemed to soothe it
enough to move it to a nearby Foundation facility.
Little did they know, they’d just obtained
one of the deadliest SCPs of all time, and
while it may have been under lock and key
for now, it seems inevitable that it would
get out and cause more violence and chaos.
Research and containment procedures for the
SCP - 096 were put under the command of Dr.
Dan, a senior researcher at the site. It was
his job to find out exactly what this being
was capable of, and the more he tested, the
more he realized that they were dealing with
something truly terrifying.
Disposable D-Class personnel were used to
figure out exactly what it was that caused
the creature to enter its attack mode. Just
as it had during the initial retrieval mission,
SCP - 096 went berserk when any of the attending
personnel saw its face. In this stage, it
would enter a period of
considerable and unstoppable
distress for one to two minutes - covering
its face and wailing loudly. When the period
of distress ended, the creature would mercilessly
slaughter every D-Class that had seen its
face, and just like with Zulu 9-A, no trace
of their bodies would be left behind.
Dr. Dan was horrified and intrigued by this
phenomenon. The creature killed anyone that
saw its face directly, but could the same
be said for indirect depictions of the creature’s
face - such as images and videos? Dr. Dan
was desperate to find out.
More D-Class personnel were brought in to
test this, to frightening results. Dr. Dan
found that the creature did indeed still enter
attack mode when people saw pictures and videos
of SCP - 096’s face. The creature seemed
to have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when it
should have had no conceivable way of knowing.
It didn’t matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the viewer
and the creature, the attack mode would still
activate. And once it did, it seemed as though
nothing could stop the creature from hunting
down the one who saw its face.
With all of this new data, special containment
procedures were devised to keep the creature
safely under lock and key. Its cell was a
5 m x 5 m x 5 m airtight steel cube, fitted
with advanced pressure sensors and laser detectors
to ensure that SCP - 096 remained in its cell
without risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature’s face. All cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden, and
weekly checks for any cracks or holes in the
containment cell were mandatory. Of course,
none of this would stop the creature if anyone
somehow saw its face. In order to solve that
little problem, Dr. Dan would need to continue
his research.
To find a method of subverting the creature’s
deadly glance, they needed to know exactly
what they were dealing with - but how could
they, when even a glance at a photo or video
of the being meant certain death? A potential
solution was proposed - creating an artistic
representation of the creature’s face, something
that hadn’t yet been attempted. But how
would they achieve such a feat? Simple - they’d
procure a D-Class prisoner with some artistic
talent, and they found one who had been a
tattoo artist before becoming a Foundation
guinea pig.
Dr. Dan formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this D-Class alive for long enough to accurately
draw an image of SCP - 096’s face: He would
be placed in a Bathysphere diving bell several
kilometers underwater, and tens of kilometers
away from the containment cell where the SCP
was being held. The D-Class was made to look
at a photograph of the creature’s face,
and then replicate that image in a pencil
sketch. Dr. Dan first
confirmed that the creature’s
attack mode is only activated by the creature’s
face by having the D-Class look at a series
of photos of the SCP’s body parts one by
one, finally finishing with its face. The
D-Class began drawing and even remarked on
how creepy the SCP’s facial features were,
despite not knowing the deadly context.
Meanwhile, back in its containment cell SCP
- 096 sensed someone viewing its face, and
entered its inconsolable crying state followed
by its attack mode. It broke out of containment
easily, and began making a beeline for the
D-Class, traversing the miles between it and
its prey. The D-Class didn’t know it as
he locked the finished drawing into a separate,
autonomous submersible, but he was already
dead. As the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface, SCP - 096 dived
into the water, and started swimming down
towards the artist. Minutes later, the bathysphere
was breached, and the D-Class was torn to
shreds.
SCP - 096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team Foxtrot-303-A, and further
testing on the drawing showed that artistic
representations of SCP - 096’s face were
in fact harmless. From this experience, we
now know that the creature has a gaunt face
with totally white eyes, possibly indicating
blindness, and a grossly
extended jaw. Nevertheless,
Dr. Dan was adamant that SCP - 096 was too
dangerous to be left alive, and requested
permission from the upper echelons of the
Foundation to terminate the creature by any
means necessary. However, the doctor’s request
would fall on deaf ears, until...
It all started with a seemingly innocent image.
(Use this image:
http://scp-wiki.wdfiles.com/local--files/incident-096-1-a/G9zmJ.jpg)
While it’s now been redacted for your safety,
the black spec inside the yellow circle was
once a minuscule image of SCP - 096, taken
unknowingly in the 1990s by a semi-professional
mountaineer. One day, they were looking at
old photographs when his eyes passed over
the tiny spec without even noticing he had
seen anything. But SCP - 096 noticed, and
began entering its attack mode.
It tore through its steel containment unit
like tissue paper, causing the release of
a nerve agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff. The monster then fled the
base and began pursuing its prey, with Mobile
Task Force Tau-1 in hot pursuit. Dr. Oleksei,
who was helping to manage the site where the
SCP was contained, was in dismay over the
situation. Dr. Dan was out of the country
at the time, trying to discover more about
the creature’s origins. However, he did
leave the Mobile Task Force with a new secret
weapon against the rampaging Shy Guy… Project
SCRAMBLE.
SCRAMBLE were state of the art goggles featuring
a new technology created by Dr. Dan, which
- using artistic renditions of 096’s facial
features - could detect and scramble the features
of SCP - 096 into an unrecognizable form,
preventing the normally deadly effect of gazing
upon on its face. In theory, this would allow
MTF Tau-1 to engage safely with 096 once its
prey had been eliminated and bring it back
into containment. But disaster struck on two
fronts. First, the prey in question was located
in a population center, creating the potential
for a huge loss of life.
And the second bigger problem was that the
SCRAMBLE technology didn’t work, as stray
pixels of the creature’s face would reach
the eyes of the task force before the internal
microprocessor had time to scramble them.
The mission turned into a death sentence,
as SCP - 096 slaughtered almost the entire
task force, as well as a number of civilians
in town - including an infant and its entire
family. It was a monumental disaster, made
even worse by a final revelation: Dr. Dan
and Dr. Oleksei had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and allowed
the resulting massacre to happen, with Dr.
Dan hoping it would be enough motivation for
Foundation Command to green-light his research
into destroying the creature.
Anything that would give him the opportunity
to kill this thing would be worth the bloodshed.
His plan worked and the SCP Foundation saw
it his way, approving his request to neutralize
SCP - 096. However, success comes at a cost
for Dr. Dan. Once he figures out a way to
finally kill the creature, though done in
the line of duty, he himself will be terminated
by the Foundation for his crimes against humanity.
But considering how much damage SCP - 096
is capable of causing if it ever got to a
major population center, or - even worse - was
ever caught on camera and broadcast to a worldwide
audience, the doctor himself would likely
deem his own death a justifiable cost. To
this day, the Foundation is researching ways
to kill the creature, and they’re still
looking for their silver bullet. And the pressure
is on. They hadn’t known about the seemingly
innocent picture that sparked the last containment
breach. The one taken decades ago, in which
the Shy Guy had only occupied four tiny pixels.
Four tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost.
So be careful where you look because who knows
how many other photos of the creature are
lurking out there, photos with an innocent
dot in the background. Your eyes glance over
it, not even noticing the little blip, until
you hear a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer, and closer, and closer. And
then... it’s already too late.
as you walk down the halls of the scp foundation
site 19 speaking in the various windows at the
anomalies contained there you might catch a
glimpse of a dark figure bent over a table
tinkering away like an artisan in his workshop a
vintage black apothecary bag sits next to him open
and if you stop and watch for a while you'll
see him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that shouldn't fit
in such a small bag a bone saw an iv stand jars
of fluorescent liquids and needles the length
of your forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after all still
it's a curious sight the shadowy man working so
diligently so quietly focused singularly on his
craft whatever that might be only one thing could
distract him from his efforts you he feels your
gaze on him and he looks up dark eyes glittering
from behind a beaked ceramic mask he reminds you
of an illustration you once saw in a book about
the black death the gear the plague doctors wore
while treating patients on their deathbeds hello
he greets you in a friendly heavily accented voice
his eyes crinkle beneath the mask and if you could
see his mouth you know he'd be smiling how are
you today dear fellow are you feeling quite well
he takes a step toward the window stretching out
one gloved hand and you suddenly realize that you
can't see where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face this is no
ordinary man do you require help i can examine
you he offers palm press flat against the glass
a chill runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on his offer
no matter how friendly he seems how good his
intentions may be you wouldn't want to let the
plague doctor treat you he sat in his containment
cell fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work table
back and forth listening to the sound it made
they had tried to confiscate his table his tools
the guards had quickly learned that he had more of
them in his bag they tried to take away his bag
from him but well that didn't go over too well
for anyone involved so he was allowed to keep it
to fashion himself a makeshift laboratory in his
lonely little cell there was a time where they
had given him test subjects fresh corpses from
the morgue for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would come to
speak with him talking of cryptobiology and the
pestilence he had dedicated himself to fighting
those days were long gone he had hidden away
pieces of the corpses tissue samples and jars of
formaldehyde he could pull out when the monotony
became too much but the days of fresh materials
of enlightened discourse with other men and women
of science were over how he missed those days the
chance to work with others as he once had what had
he done wrong all he did was treat the sick sure
they didn't always understand their illness didn't
want to receive their medicine but that wasn't a
choice for the patient to make that should have
been up to the physician perhaps they didn't trust
his expertise didn't see how his work served the
greater good like those who watched jonas salk
invent the polio vaccine or louis pasteur rid milk
of bacteria they were confused by the advanced
scientific practices and feared that which
they did not understand he could forgive them
for their ignorance he was magnanimous that way
if only they would let him out of this infernal
room he could prove his work's worth to them he
could cure them all begin a new era of wellness
and peace worldwide he didn't exactly sleep but
when he rested on his little cot in the corner
of the room he dreamed of that future of a world
healed by his touch a knock at the door stirred
him from his reverie someone someone was at the
door of his containment cell he glanced at the
little window and saw a guard there with a tray of
food he greeted the man with an enthusiastic wave
sustenance he didn't require the food for
survival of course but it helped his mind
work more efficiently it reminded him of a time
before these fluorescent lights and these same
four walls of crusty bread with fresh butter
by the banks of the sin the little slot opened
in the door and the tray was shoved through there
was bread just as he hoped a small dish of butter
pot of jam and a cup of tea still seeming he
picked up the cup at first taking a deep breath
ah an herbal blend with fresh lavender lovely he
couldn't see the guard through the window anymore
but he called out to him just the same thank you
for the libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he could have
gotten a better look at the man seen the power
of his complexion a tremor in his hand he thought
he had spotted sweat beating on his forehead could
he be ill the case required further examination
to be certain he sighed clutching the cup of tea
tighter in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him work why must they scream at the sight
of his efforts flee from his instruments it didn't
seem fair still the pursuit of science rarely was
a glamorous one he had learned as much over the
centuries one day though history would look back
on him kindly of this he could be certain he was
just settling in and beginning to spread butter
across the admittedly stale bread when a horrible
sound shook him to attention he had heard the
noise before though he had never seen its source
it was an ear splitting scream a whale of pure
agony like the sound of a wounded wild animal he
had heard many many screams during his life from
patients and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into custody of
the foundation he had never heard a scream quite
like this one it was pure rage devastation and
suffering mixed together wet with tears and loud
enough to rip through human vocal folds whatever
was crying out it was no mere man more screams
answered it and these were very much human these
sounds were more familiar to him shrieks of pain
a fear of desperate but futile attempts to escape
then the meaty thud of bodies falling to the floor
of torn off limbs hitting walls and windows a loud
crash and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the halls scientific
curiosity got the better of the doctor and he
found himself moving back to his little window
face pressed to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of anything just
guards running down the hall weapons drawn he saw
one of them fire heard the gunshot ring out but
what was he firing at then he saw it a pale blur
darting past the door whatever it was it didn't
so much as flinch when the bullet ricocheted
off its skin a long thin arm crashed against
the door knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he steadied himself and climbed back
to his feet taking in the damage done to the door
it was crumpled in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it was already
gone from the sounds of chaos in the distance it
had disappeared around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of the door
to his containment cell it was useless now hanging
loose and open well that was an invitation he was
hardly about to decline he grabbed his trusty bag
tossed his scalpel back inside and set off to see
what all the commotion was it was easy enough
to follow the trail of blood stark and vivid
red against the white tile floor and the sound of
gunfire human screams and that loud long painful
whale he had heard before he walked at a leisurely
pace taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found a mound of
bodies guards and scientists beaten and bloodied
almost beyond recognition it was quiet here save
for one sound the sound of weeping there in the
corner huddled over with its face to the wall was
a pale thin figure its shoulders heaving with the
force of its sobs this poor soul was clearly in
great distress it was a peculiar sight hairless
and white extended arms wrapped around itself
as it cried excuse me the doctor cried out to
the pitiful creature are you alright do you need
assistance it didn't answer it just continued to
cry had something so despondent been responsible
for this destruction the dozens of corpses the
smashed in walls the crumbled doors and shattered
windows it seemed impossible sure it was large and
looked strong but he had never seen a monster cry
before this couldn't be a dangerous creature not
when it was so sad he would help it but first he
would attend to some of these bodies he sat his
bag on the ground and pulled out several vials of
liquid a set of syringes and a variety of other
surgical tools he might need now after such a long
hiatus he could resume his work in a meaningful
way he couldn't be certain how long he worked
reviving these poor souls and reconstructing their
bodies as the pale creature wept in the corner
the sobbing faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he removed a
liver here placed it in a chest cavity there poked
and prodded injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures one by one
the milky eyes fluttered open rigor mortis stiff
joints creaked into motion sallow faces looking at
his with the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need to thank
him with their words the work was its own reward
he expected more guards to arrive to attempt to
contain the situation but none came even as
the alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature he didn't seem to notice his presence at
all not even when he had brought all of the intact
corpses back to life the patient shuffled around
the room aimlessly waiting for orders of some kind
the doctor tapped one on the shoulder and handed
the reborn man a vial of thick black medicine give
this to the poor fellow in the corner please it
wasn't much but it should calm him provide some
relief from his suffering the corpse nodded mouth
hanging loose and open an eyeball dangling unseen
from the socket he shuffled over to the strange
creature and held out the vial to it it turned
lifting its head and as it locked eyes with the
cured patient something shifted in its face its
mouth opened wide impossibly wide and a treat that
same terrible sound as before tears streamed from
its colorless eyes its arms shaking with unbridled
rage has its jaws locked around the patient's head
like a boa constrictor in one fluid motion
it swallowed the revived man whole while the
doctor watched in shock he had been wrong this
was not an innocent creature caught in the wrong
place at the wrong time this creature whatever
it was was deeply sick he had never seen such an
advanced aggressive case of the pestilence he'd
heard rumors of course but never encountered it
firsthand as a doctor he had sworn to do no harm
but in a drastic situation drastic measures have
to be taken it was well known by himself and the
doctors at this foundation that he could cause any
and all biological functions in an organism to
cease with a single touch and so he approached
the creature arm outstretched ready to administer
that necessary touch to protect the rest of his
patients as he approached the creature turned to
him its eyes wide and blank an endless stream of
tears pouring from them spilling onto the floor
it shrieked again mouth stretching wide enough
to engulf his entire head and ran toward him at
a breakneck speed i am so sorry you are not well
the doctor said simply as his hand pressed to the
creature's chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might mistake
for gloves made contact with the unpigmented
skin of the beast its eyes closed its muscles went
slack and it collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thigh the doctor paced around the fallen creature
taking in the sight then something strange caught
his eye the creature's chest still rose and fell
was it his imagination he checked its pulse and
thought it was slow and faint and though was
slow and faint it was very much present the
creature was still alive it had merely been
rendered unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious very curious indeed he
muttered perhaps there were comorbidities present
other infections aside from the pestilence which
rendered the creature unnaturally strong resilient
to the usual courses of treatment what would cause
these abilities this intense aggression it seemed
to be brought on whenever someone looked at the
entity's face if only he studied psychology more
the science of the mind and its inner workings
since he had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could communicate using
language at all there was only one way to find
out more about how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for himself it
was slow work getting the massive creature back
to the doctor's containment cell he required the
help of his cured patients who grasped it
by its massive limbs and dragged the limp
body through the halls once back in a familiar
environment his work table ready and waiting the
doctor instructed his assistants to place the new
patient on the table it was a bit small unable to
accommodate the creature's distended limbs but
if he attempted to use an official foundation
laboratory he risked discovery and subsequent
interruption so it would have to suffice first
he set up an iv stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the creature's
skin was nearly translucent now that he could
be certain the creature would not wake during
surgery he could make the first incision scalpel
he held out a hand and his favorite surgical blade
was placed in it by one of the helpful patients
thank you he slid the scalpel along the hairline
of the creature or where the hairline would be
if it weren't completely bald once the scalp was
removed he set it aside for later when it could
be reattached bonsa please he held out his hand
again and again his assistant gave him the proper
tool this however was when things got strange the
doctor had always been a deft hand at cutting he'd
once even received tutelage from the great robert
liston but no matter how hard he tried to saw it
never left a scratch on the creature's skeleton
naturally this was somewhat frustrating he wanted
to study the creature's brain tissue to get a
sense for what was going up there neurologically
and he couldn't do that if it was impossible to
saw off the creature's cranial cap he blunted two
of his favorite saws while trying thankfully there
was still a solution to access the beast's gray
matter a little trick he learned while studying
the funerary practices of the ancient egyptians
he produced a long curved hook from his bag and
inserted it up the creature's nasal passage with
some fine maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible shame that
he needed to do it piece by piece via the nasal
passage but one makes do all that was left was
to sew the skin of the creature's head back into
place it was mid-stitch when a voice interrupted
his careful work nearly making him drop the needle
hey what are you doing he looked up to find a
guard aiming a gun at his face excuse me i am in
surgery at the moment please do not interrupt he
admonished the guard but the man did not listen or
lower his weapon in fact he shouted something
into the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into the skull
of the patient standing at his side how dare you
the doctor cried readying himself to confront
the guard but it was too late dozens of other
guards were swarming the room and neutralizing
his assistance some in hazmat suits grabbed his
arms and pulled him away from the creature on the
operating table no matter how hard he fought or
how loudly he protested then something incredible
happened something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly at the
guard closest to it and the two saw one another's
faces the guard tensed preparing for the worst but
nothing came the creature simply stared placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing and flesh no mouth
opening wider and wider to swallow the manhole i
did it the doctor shouted overcome with elation
i've cured you now begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the shockingly
calm creature away back to its containment cell
the doctor's door was repaired and he was
returned to his state of captivity but he
never forgot the patient he helped that day
and how marvelous it felt to do such a good
deed meanwhile scp-096's brain regrew within
the hour and caused another massive containment
breach murdering a variety of researchers and
guards but the staff agreed not to tell scp-049
about any of this better to just let him have
this one he really seemed like he needed a win
A very strange anomaly sits in a humanoid
containment cell in the minimum security wing
of Site 17.
He walks, talks, and looks like a man, but
everything else is convoluted in a question
mark.
This is SCP-343 - Who, like his namesake,
God, is likely to cause arguments whenever
he’s brought up.
Is he the creator of all that exists?
The basis for the Abrahamic Faiths?
Or is he a pretender - A reality warper with
immense power and a predilection towards delusion?
A courtesan of the House of Malidraug?
Matthew?
Methuselah?
Yahweh?
Who knows?
Really, it depends on who you ask, and which
stories you choose to believe.
And few people enjoy a good story more than
SCP-343 himself.
If, one day, you take the time to visit him
in his room, and ask him to reveal a page
in the long book of his personal history,
he might be kind enough to tell you a story.
A story like this - Of an encounter with something
monstrous, that few others could hope to survive
meeting face to face…
Rewind a few thousand years.
Nobody knows how many, exactly.
God - as he chooses to dub himself - walked
across the cracked ground on worn sandals.
It’d been some time since he’d seen an
animal around here, and even longer since
he’d seen a human being.
Not that this bothered him.
He’d never been bothered by his own company
on a long walk like this.
Of course, he could have
sped up time or teleported,
but where was the fun in that?
He was a tourist in the world of sensation.
Of experience.
Of flesh, bone, dirt, blood, and sand.
After all, where’s the fun in creating a
whole universe if you can’t drop in now
and then to visit and do as the Romans do?
Not that the Romans would be around for another
few thousand years.
Even Atlas must occasionally shift the weight
of the globe from his shoulders for a jaunt
around the cosmic neighborhood, and whatever
passes for “fresh air” in the vacuum.
God whistled a tune to himself.
It was a craggy, mountainous region he’d
found himself in.
The distant peaks had frosted caps.
A breathtaking place, where many truly had
their breaths taken away.
How humans will so happily risk their lives
to do something extraordinary.
It never ceased to amaze him.
His stomach rumbled.
Oh, how he enjoyed that sensation.
One of the funny little quirks of this human
form that he’d weaved for himself.
It was no reason to be concerned - If memory
served, from his last trip through the area
a few decades before, there was a friendly
village not far from here.
They had always accepted him as a genial stranger,
having no knowledge of his true power.
God had always believed that a person’s
goodness is defined by how they treat those
from whom they had nothing to gain.
So it caused him great concern as he approached
the village, and saw great plumes of smoke
rising into the sky.
He was so shocked by this that he decided
to break his rule about walking as a man,
in case there was still some way he could
help.
With a snap of his fingers, he disappeared
and reappeared in the center of the village’s
town square.
Total devastation.
Huts and houses had been torn asunder.
Broken weapons lay on the ground.
Some places were on fire, others smeared with
streaks of blood, like some terrible battle
had occurred here.
But something was wrong.
No bodies.
Not one, from defender or assailant.
How could a thriving village be so thoroughly
destroyed, and not leave a single corpse?
It was an act so bizarre and depraved that
it even left God puzzling.
That was another downside of his human form:
Here, on earth, he didn’t have access to
true omniscience.
How could a mere human mind, bound by the
constraints of linear time, ever truly comprehend
the totality of existence?
Even attempting to do that here would melt
the brain of his human body in its skull,
and leave it dribbling out of his nose and
ears.
Instead, he chose to walk around the ruins
of the village and investigate firsthand.
Arrows and broken spears and swords littered
the ground.
Some buildings were demolished, but there
were no tracks or stray projectiles that could
suggest the presence of siege weapons.
No, these buildings looked like they were
ripped apart.
Some even still had claw marks…
What terrible beast could have set upon this
town and done this?
Then, he heard a voice, quiet and pleading
beneath some nearby rubble.
A survivor!
He rushed over to the pile and evaporated
it with a thought, Underneath, a feeble old
man, covered in stone dust, was quivering.
God helped him up and guided him into one
of the few remaining huts still standing in
the village.
They both took seats - God held up two hands,
cradling empty space.
Two cups suddenly occupied that space, both
filled with warm, healing tea.
He passed the old man one of the cups while
sipping from his own.
He asked the old man if he’d seen what had
happened.
The old man told him, no, he hadn’t seen
anything in decades.
He’d been rendered blind in his youth.
Little did either of them know, that very
blindness was the only reason he was the sole
survivor of the massacre.
The blind man told God that one of the village’s
scouts had gone up into the mountain with
a small hunting party.
The group was gone for days, until one of
the members - the youngest among them - returned,
weeping, frostbitten, and covered in blood.
He said that his friends had been killed by
a beast in the mountains.
Something that looked almost like a man, but
terribly wrong.
And its face.
Its awful, awful face.
He would never forget it.
He was just lucky to escape with his life
when the others were torn apart.
But when the young man returned, he’d brought
the shadow of death with him.
It was a curse that doomed the entire village
- men, women, and children - to a terrible
fate.
And that fate was upon them a mere hour after
the survivor had returned.
Of course, there were gaps in the blind man’s
understanding, given he was lacking one of
his major senses.
But the sounds he could describe with perfect
clarity.
It was faint and distant at first.
That awful wail, and the galloping.
Hands and feet thundering against the ground,
faster than any horse could move.
Getting closer and closer and closer.
Another villager saw it approaching and screamed,
then it was upon them.
The villagers screamed but it screamed louder.
Always wailing and shrieking and sobbing like
a monster crawled straight up from hell.
People tried to fight it, by the sounds of
it.
The blind man, with teary, blank eyes, recalled
the sounds of arrows nocking and swords clashing
against…
Something.
But even their greatest warriors had screamed
and died.
Those who saw it and tried to flee and hide
were slaughtered all the same.
Soon enough, there were only two sounds left
in the village.
The monster and the blind man, both weeping.
He didn’t understand why it never took him.
It wasn’t fair.
It took everything else.
To leave him here, alive, when everyone and
everything he’d ever known was destroyed,
was a greater punishment than even death.
After killing all of these innocents, the
monster had simply wandered off to the mountains
again, the sound of its quiet sobs getting
smaller and smaller until it was gone altogether.
God comforted the blind man as he wept for
the loss of all his loved ones.
He told the blind man that he would venture
up to the mountains himself and confront the
creature on its own territory, and, at the
very least, find out why it had done this
terrible thing.
But first, he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place.
He placed a hand on the blind man’s shoulder
and he vanished.
He would appear in another friendly village,
miles away.
God sent a silent message into the minds of
every villager: Take good care of this man.
He has undergone horrors you can’t even
imagine.
Your kindness will be rewarded later, for
that, you have my promise.
God sighed and turned his tired eyes to the
distant mountains.
A monster lurked up there - Perhaps one of
his own creations, or maybe a corruption of
one of his creations.
Either way, whatever existed without his knowledge
existed without his consent, and he intended
to know of the beast in the mountains.
Though given what he’d seen already, he
didn’t expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon.
Miles away, up in the mountains, the creature
licked the blood from its cracked lips.
It looked like it might once have been a human
being or something that aspired to humanity,
or mocked it with its very existence.
It was a huge, gangling beast, skin alabaster,
eyes empty and soulless, dribbling rivulets
of burning tears down a hideous, gaunt face.
It crawled into the frozen mouth of a cave
with great icicle fangs, wheezing and weeping.
All it ever wanted was to be alone.
Why did they have to keep interfering?
Didn’t they know what happened?
All the terrible things they’d made it do…
The creature curled its long, gangly body
into the fetal position, scratching great
ruts into the sides of its bald cranium with
long, sharp fingers.
Terrible things.
Terrible, terrible things…
And then there was a brilliant flash, just
a few feet away.
The monster was surprised, it turned to see
a figure silhouetted in the mouth of the cave.
He wore sandals and thin robes.
His eyes glowed with a kind of power that
the monster didn’t recognize.
This stranger stared at the monster without
an ounce of fear in his heart: He stared right
into its eyes, unwavering.
No!
No, no, no, no!
It could feel it again.
The rage bubbling up, deep down.
A cauldron of seething anger.
It hated the feeling, like being lowered into
a vat of molten metal.
Unspeakable fire and pain coursing through
every vessel.
It began to weep and scream while the stranger
in the cave mouth just watched, not moving
a muscle.
“Do you know who I am?”
the stranger asked with a deep voice that
betrayed almost infinite power, knowledge,
and wisdom.
But it wouldn’t change the outcome here.
The monster bounded at him at speeds that
wouldn’t be seen again until jet planes
and bullet trains are invented millennia into
the future.
Its jaws were hanging impossibly wide, fangs
borne, its arms extended and deadly claws
ready to strike.
But before those terrible hands could close
around the stranger, he vanished.
The monster stumbled and rolled across the
snow, confused.
What trickery was being used here?
“I’ll take that as a no,” said the voice
from behind him.
“You ought to show your father some respect.
More respect than you gave to those poor people
down in the village, at least.”
Seething, the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness of
the cave, staring at him.
But the beast didn’t have the capacity for
awe or holy terror.
Only violence.
Boundless, limitless, unstoppable violence.
It darted towards the stranger again, trying
to strike at him.
Somehow, it was like fighting an empty robe.
Not a single one of its deadly strikes seemed
to hit the stranger.
The stranger leaped backwards, putting some
space between himself and the monster but
still not breaking a sweat.
He breathed in deeply, then exhaled.
The breath came out like a mighty typhoon,
shocking even the monster with its sudden
force.
It was blown backwards, a leaf in the wind,
until its long claws dug into the ground and
anchored it in place.
The stranger gave a wry smile at this, impressed.
“My, my, you’re certainly a tenacious
one, aren’t you?” he said.
“Perhaps we can talk for a little while
instead of fighting.
I want to know why you killed all those people.”
No answer.
The beast roared, its mighty limbs pounding
into the ground as it closed the gap between
itself and the stranger in fractions of a
second.
It would kill him.
Rend him.
Destroy him just like all the others.
He’d left it no choice!
Suddenly, the ground below it seemed to give
away.
The creature was confused.
It looked down to see that the ancient stone
below had somehow taken on the properties
of a liquid, and it was sinking.
The beast panicked and began to thrash.
It was a strong swimmer, but it didn’t expect
to need to swim here.
The shock was too much, and soon, the ground
submerged it entirely, muffling its terrible
roars and shrieks.
And just like that, the ground was solid again,
trapping the beast inside.
The stranger stepped forward and looked at
the ground.
“A much-needed time out,” he said.
“You do yourself no good struggling like
this.”
Despite its terrible capacity for evil, God
couldn’t help but admire the beast, at least
on the level of construction.
It was so pared down, so unburdened.
A killer to the core, but seemingly unkillable.
Had he made this creature?
Billions of species and the species those,
in turn, had created through billions of years
of breeding and evolution, and somewhere along
the line, this thing happened.
It was easy even for the universe’s creator
to lose track of some of the tinier variables.
And in the grand scheme of things, even this
monster was still a tiny variable.
But right here, right now, it was still one
hell of a problem.
The ground rumbled below God.
Cracks formed.
The mountain peak shook.
God raised an eyebrow, genuinely impressed,
as the monster ripped free of its stone prison
and re-entered the fray.
It roared and screamed still, its blank eyes
fixed on him.
Its skeletal body throbbed and heaved with
power.
Unlike any other creature in nature, it was
almost like, the longer their conflict went
on, the more energized the beast became.
God sighed.
All those poor villagers.
They never stood a chance against this monster.
It lunged for him, even faster and stronger
than before.
He teleported out of the way in the nick of
time and the beast’s claws cleaved through
a nearby cave wall, effortless.
God materialized nearby, but he didn’t have
time to speak.
The beast lunged again, and again, and again.
Every time he reappeared, the beast went for
him with impossible speed.
Deciding to widen the
playing field, God teleported
to the top of the mountain.
The creature, somehow sensing his presence,
vaulted upwards and tunneled through the roof
of the cave, bursting out of the ground in
front of God, who was floating just slightly
off the ground.
“It would be wise of you to stop,” God
carefully intoned.
“All this time, you know, I’ve been going
easy on you.
You don’t want to find out what the wrath
of God looks like.”
Storm clouds were gathering above.
Mighty thunder roared across the sky.
The beast was undeterred.
It roared and galloped towards God.
And God, in turn, called down a response.
A volley of lightning the likes of which the
world has never seen before or since struck
down on the charging monster.
The sudden white flash could sting the eyes
from miles away.
The monster shrieked from the blast, feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and atomize in
the sheer heat of the electricity around it.
It could smell itself cooking.
The lightning blasts only lasted for a few
seconds, but for the beast, it felt like an
eternity.
When the onslaught stopped, the air was still
heavy with electrical potential.
God stared down at the black scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the creature
had been standing.
All the snow within the mile had been evaporated
by the blast.
It was a raw display of the power of nature
that would make even Zeus tremble in his sandals.
And yet…
There was still movement.
Something started to get up from the burnt
patch where nothing should be left alive.
A blackened skeleton, rising shakily from
the ash but still very much alive.
As it started to rise, new flesh began growing
over the bones, little by little.
Even God was astonished by the sight of it.
He’d never seen a creature cling so ardently
to life in spite of having truly unsurmountable
power amassed against it.
It was up against God, and still, it fought.
The monster tottered on its freakishly long
limbs, still disoriented, unusually staggered
for a creature driven by such single-minded,
violent purpose.
When enough of its face grew back to do so,
it began to weep and sob again, tears streaking
down its terrible face.
Looking at this creature, after all this,
God couldn’t help but feel a new emotion:
Pity.
He lowered himself to the ground and approached
the creature.
Like none had ever done before, he gathered
it up into his arms and held it, feeling its
heaving, wretched sobs against him.
This beast was in so much pain.
He could feel it, radiating from within.
“Speak, my son,” God said in a soft, fatherly
voice.
And for the first and only time, the monster
spoke,
“Can’t look.
Can’t see.
Make me hurt people.
Don’t want hurt people.
Can’t look, can’t look.
Please.”
That was all it managed to choke out before
devolving back into unintelligible babble.
But it was enough.
Enough for God to understand its pain.
He did not know if it would be right to change
the monster’s nature - is it ever right
to truly change anyone’s nature?
- but it was within his almost limitless power
to grant it one reprieve from its pain.
He settled the beast in the snow below him.
It was quiet and still.
And God said unto the beast, “Rest now,
child.
Rest for thousands of years, if you must.
I hope only that when you eventually awaken,
you feel differently…”
And so another story from the catalog of SCP-343.
Of course, it leaves us with certain questions,
chief among them being: Is it true?
Did 343 and 096 have this chance encounter
long ago, or is this just another tall tale
from an anomaly who fancies himself a deity?
We have our truth, and you have yours.
Let us know what you believe down below in
the comments.
What do you do, when the sun turns wrong?
When light, which once represented life, joy,
and warmth becomes a symbol
of death and destruction?
Do you hide inside, shutter the windows, keep
out the light by any means necessary?
Do you retreat underground, where the sun’s
rays cannot penetrate, burrowing into the
dark and the cold?
Do you simply give yourself to it, accept
that there is no escaping something so vast,
so far-reaching as sunlight itself, and allow
yourself to be lost in the end of all things?
We’ve covered this possibility before, SCP-001,
“When Day Breaks”, or S.D.
Locke’s Proposal.
It’s difficult to know what any given person
might do in such harrowing circumstances.
After all, we have always learned to love
the light and fear the darkness.
It turns our very understanding of reality
upside down to have that paradigm shifted,
the dark becoming safety and the light becoming
death.
The source of all life on earth, of all warmth,
transforming in an instant from the sun as
we know it to an Apollyon Class SCP that melts
all living organisms that cross into its gaze.
But what about a being that has always feared
the light?
Something that prioritizes solitude, and never
ever wants to be seen?
How might it live out those darkened days?
Today, we’re taking a look at what happens
when Daybreak meets a familiar face, even
if a constantly hidden one: SCP-096.
SCP-096, or “The Shy Guy,” is something
of a celebrity around here.
It is a humanoid creature with long, distended
arms, pale skin, and a jaw that can open four
times wider than an ordinary human’s.
There is only one thing, above all else, that
this entity desires: for no one to see its
face.
When someone views its face, it flies into
an uncontrollable rage, and seems to have
no other option but to destroy the person
who has seen it.
So, it is unlikely that a creature so intent
on solitude would be in much danger from the
transformed sun.
In fact, it might even be a positive thing,
and for some time it was.
With so many human beings gone, reduced to
gelatinous masses with no desire but to slither
around in the ghoulish sunlight and merge
with one another, there were fewer people
to observe his face than ever.
He could stay inside and know, with almost
complete certainty, that no one would come
to bother him.
No one was coming to look at him, and there
were no more visitors, researchers poking
and prodding, that might sneak a look at his
face.
And so, he stayed there, in the room that
had served as his containment unit before
the world turned upside down.
The masses of flesh that once were humans
did not concern him, as they never looked
at his face.
All he did was stay in his room, and never
go outside.
The outside frightened him terribly, though
he was not concerned with the deadly sunlight
or the possibility of it melting him as it
had so many others.
He was much more afraid that someone, some
unlikely survivor clinging to their original
life, might look at him.
That they might see his face.
That was simply too distressing to risk.
He would much rather stay alone, in his old
cell, weeping softly in the shadows.
One day, though we couldn’t say how many
days after the end of things it had been,
he was weeping alone in his former cell.
The days blurred together, spent the same
way, and time had lost much of its meaning.
Through the echoing sound of his sobs, and
the sloshing sounds of the creatures outside,
a woman’s voice cut through.
It was faint, but he could make out what she
was saying.
She was calling out for help, asking if anyone
had any food or fresh water.
The sound was getting louder, closer, accompanied
by the disconcerting thump of her footsteps.
She was coming down the hall, as much as it
could be called a hall anymore.
She was coming toward his room, to disrupt
his miserable peace.
He heard her steps cross the threshold of
his room, and her voice broke into a terrified
scream, no doubt at the unexpected sight of
a pale, naked creature weeping in the corner
of what she expected to be an empty room.
Startled by the first loud sound he’d heard
in a long time, in a world that had mostly
been silent since the initial outpouring of
agonized screams had faded into the soft slap
of flesh and slime on the ground, he turned
around.
He shouldn’t, ordinarily he wouldn’t,
but he couldn’t stop himself.
There, he saw a woman, wide eyes filled with
tears, face streaked with dirt, a small child
next to her holding her hand and clinging
to her leg.
Just as he saw the woman, she saw him.
She saw…his face.
Anger boiled over inside of him, and he let
out a scream, wild, primal, and filled with
inhuman rage.
She could not be looking at him, seeing his
face.
He couldn’t let her.
The woman ran with the child in tow, panicked
by the wild roar and the sight of him standing
upright before her.
The anger faded as she left his site, making
her way down the hall and to the stairs.
But then, he remembered: she had seen his
face.
He could not let her leave.
It was time to do something he never thought
he’d have to do again: hunt.
His heightened senses picked up the sound
of muffled footsteps, coming up through the
floor below him.
She was downstairs, just beneath the floor
where he was standing.
His instincts kicked in, and his body moved
almost of its own accord.
He lifted his long, long arms above his head,
and drove his hands down into the floor.
It was weakened by the ravages of the elements
and time, and crumbled under his unnatural
strength.
He dug his claws into the plaster, tearing
it apart and cracking it into pieces.
He pushed his claws in, deeper and deeper,
until he could feel them breaking through
to the other side.
He pulled the floor apart until the hole was
wide enough to fit through, then dropped down
to the room below.
He spotted the woman’s back, fleeing through
the door, just as he landed.
She was getting away!
He tore after her, ripping through concrete
and steel, destroying everything in his path
in a mad dash for the object of his rage.
He had to catch her, she could not be allowed
to leave.
She looked over her shoulder at him, her face
a mask of pure terror.
She knew, just as he knew, that there was
no escape in sight.
In his single-minded
obsession, and her desperation
to escape from him, neither of them noticed
that she had run so far and so carelessly
that she was now outside of the building.
She had crossed from the shadows, into the
harsh light of the sun.
The woman’s eyes widened in grim understanding
of her fate.
He could only watch, helplessly, as her body
began to succumb to the vicious rays.
Almost instantly, she began to melt.
As it was the closest to the sun, her head
was the first to go.
Her nose drooped like hot wax, dripping as
it went until it slumped off her face and
landed on the ground with a sickening splash.
Her eyes were next, popping out of their sockets
and hanging, loose and limp, on her cheeks
and dangling from sinewy strands.
She tried, in vain, to stuff them back into
place, but they squished in her hands like
overripe fruit.
She attempted to run into the comparative
safety of the ruined building, but her feet
were already beginning to spread out onto
the street, melting into a sticky red smear
on the pavement.
Her legs crumbled beneath her, and she collapsed
to the ground, her face leaving a trail of
gelatinous flesh as it landed.
She tried, uselessly, to drag herself along
the ground back into the darkness, but her
arms were melting into the dirt, mixing with
it into a horrible red mud.
She let out a last scream of agony, but the
sound turned to a thick gurgle as her lips
fused together and her mouth
melted into nothingness.
He watched it all, sobbing and roaring in
frustration.
She was gone, and he would
never get the satisfaction
of ending her.
The infernal sun had stolen her from him.
Now she was nothing but a wet shadow, like
the rest of the humans had become long ago.
He heard the sound of a soft sob behind him,
a tiny human voice.
He turned, looking for the source.
There, was the little girl.
He had almost forgotten about her.
She was calling out for her mother and crying,
and she was looking right at him.
Right at his face.
He waited for the anger to overtake him, but
instead…there was nothing.
Why wasn’t he angry?
She was looking at his face, so why?
Then he realized: her eyes were on him, but
she did not see him.
She was blind.
She approached the creature,
her arms outstretched,
following the sound of his crying.
She touched his hand with her own tiny fingers,
so small and fragile, and asked, “Mommy?”
Then, he felt something he had never felt
before.
Tenderness, care, a desire to protect this
tiny innocent being.
It was the first time he had ever felt warm,
ever felt anything but sadness, anger, or
fear.
Overcome with this softness, he wrapped his
arms around the child and hugged her close.
She hugged him back, tightly, and the room
went quiet as they both stopped crying.
From that day on, they became a family of
sorts.
They lived together, and he took care of her.
She didn’t know what he looked like, and
had no idea he might be something to fear.
To her, he was safety.
He was home.
For the first time in his long, awful life,
he felt like a human instead of a monster.
He would scavenge food for her, bring her
fresh water, lay down stolen blankets and
pillows so she would have a soft place to
rest.
He even found her a ratty, worn teddy bear
amongst the rubble and gave it to her as a
gift.
She clutched it to her chest and thanked him,
and for once his tears were those of joy.
In this cursed world, they had found something
like happiness in one another.
He knew he would protect her no matter what.
Then, one day, everything changed.
The creature and the little girl were playing
in the abandoned site, making up little games
together, when he took a break to look out
the window and monitor their surroundings.
Outside, the evil red sun waited.
When he turned back, the little girl was gone.
One of the shadowy creatures, once human,
was imitating his voice to lure her away.
He could hear it in the distance, and her
tiny footsteps following it.
He chased after her, the only thing he had
ever loved, and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light.
She screamed as one of her arms began to melt
in the light, and he knew what he had to do.
He grabbed her and pulled her back inside,
using his body to shield her from the horrible
rays.
As he wept over her, his tears stopped her
body from melting any further, but his body
continued to fall apart.
It was too late for him.
He ran, as far away as he could.
Once he transformed, he did not want to end
up hurting the girl.
He ran until his legs melted away and he could
not run anymore.
He had reached the shoreline, and stared out
at the ocean, unable to move any more.
He screamed, a final time,
in agony, in heartbreak,
in mourning for the happiness he had finally
found and now would lose.
But at least he knew, as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone, that the girl would
be safe.
And then, he was gone, and the world was quiet.
The day-to-day routine of Dr. Gears consisted
of a few constants: piping hot cups of black,
unsweetened coffee, plain dry wheat toast,
the soothing sounds of his favorite white
noise machine, and the endless carousel of
experiments with SCP-914.
Not that he was complaining, he was perfectly
content to spend his time supervising one
of the few anomalies he crossed paths with
on a regular basis that was unlikely to kill
or maim him in any way.
Not that the Clockworks hadn't produced its
fair share of unpredictable results over the
years of extensive testing.
It had definitely offered up more than a few
surprises.
And anyone who knew Dr. Gears knew that he
was not especially fond of surprises.
Dr. Bright had attempted to throw a surprise
birthday party for the man once, but when
he turned on the lights and fired the confetti
cannon, all Dr. Gears did in response was
give a deep sigh and say "Really, Jack?
You're making a spectacle of yourself."
Still, he had resigned himself long ago to
the fact that supervising the experiments
with SCP-914 meant witnessing
some truly unpredictable
outcomes.
How could he forget the time Researcher Blais
tested an incandescent light bulb on the setting
"Very Fine," and the machine
spat out an anthropomorphic
humanoid lightbulb that spoke in German-accented
English and claimed to be Thomas Edison himself.
This was, of course, impossible, as historical
records surely would have indicated if Thomas
Edison was a walking talking lightbulb rather
than a human man.
The imposter was eventually incinerated after
its presence became too irritating to ignore.
And then there was the time Researcher Thompson
filled out a Dungeons and Dragons character
sheet and placed it into the machine on the
setting "Very Fine."
The output produced was a sheet of paper promoting
the previously nonexistent tabletop roleplaying
game Fear in the Foundation.
Whenever a person read the paper, they would
suddenly find themselves in an out-of-body
experience where they were inside of the game's
world, which contained several characters
related to the SCP Foundation, as well as
items and locations based
on real-world counterparts.
A subject in this state would only snap back
to reality after winning or dying in the game.
Researcher Jacobson rolled a 1 on stealth
and saw SCP-096's face in the game, and was
later found dead in the anomalous item storage
wing.
There was no shortage of Foundation staff
trying to use the machine for personal gain,
too.
Dr. Naismith placed his credit card inside
on the setting "Very Fine," using it to produce
a card covered in unidentified corporate insignias
and reading “RANK-ALEPH
INFINITE MONEY PRIVILEGES.”
When Dr. Coltrane issued a written warning,
Dr. Naismith took that warning and then placed
it into the machine on the same setting, producing
a piece of official documentation from the
O5 council in support of his Infinite Money
Privileges.
Junior Researcher Summers attempted to use
SCP-914 in a misguided
attempt at self-improvement,
placing not an object, but herself in the
intake booth before running the machine on
the setting "Very Fine."
It cleared her skin, lengthened her hair,
and improved her figure.
This was, of course, in violation of several
employee guidelines, and she was promptly
dismissed after emerging from SCP-914.
Dr. Veritas left a note in the experiment
log following this incident, reading: "By
the time we realized what she was actually
doing, it was too late to stop her.
Needless to say, she's since been terminated,
and I hope I don't need to tell you all not
to do it again."
And with that, the guidance was clear: no
one was permitted to use SCP-914 for personal
gain, or to change anything about themselves.
Potential complications were too risky, not
to mention the conflicts of interest that
would be introduced into what should be an
impartial research process.
As scientific objectivity's biggest fan, Dr.
Gears couldn't agree more.
So, as he settled in for the day's round of
tests, he intended to keep a watchful eye
on things and ensure that no funny business
would take place.
He didn't have much reason for concern, as
his colleague Dr. Bonita prepped her research
materials.
She was working with two items: a small replica
of Michelangelo's sculpture of David, and
a sealed envelope containing something that
was to be handled with extreme caution, a
photograph of SCP-096's face.
She planned to place the items inside on the
"Very Fine" setting, in an attempt to see
what result might be produced from combining
an ideal of traditional beauty standards with
the image of a creature that felt such profound
shame and distress at its own appearance that
it would destroy anyone who looked at its
face.
Like any good scientist, Dr. Bonita wanted
to remove any unnecessary variables from her
experiment.
So, as she placed her items inside the intake
booth, she slowly, delicately, unsealed the
envelope.
She wanted to put the picture inside by itself,
without the extra element of the envelope
potentially complicating things.
Unfortunately, like Marie
Curie slowly, unintentionally
poisoning herself with her own research materials,
she didn't truly understand the danger of
what she held in her hands.
Just as she was setting the photograph down,
her eyes flickered to the image.
Before she could even stop herself, before
she could look away or squeeze her eyes shut,
she caught a glimpse of the one thing she
should never look at: SCP-096's face.
She gasped and slammed the photograph down,
but she knew it was too late.
The sound of an inhuman shriek coming from
across the facility signaled that she was
right.
It was coming for her, and nothing in the
world could stop it.
In a containment cell on the other side of
the facility, Foundation staff were horrified
as they heard the telltale scream of an enraged
SCP-096.
The pale, thin creature, once huddled in the
corner silently, had stretched to its full
height of 2.38 meters, and was screaming,
sobbing, wailing in gibberish, and beginning
to tear its way out of its chamber.
Guards tried their best to subdue the entity,
firing their weapons at it, but the bullets
did nothing to damage the creature's pale
flesh or stop its movements.
It ripped through the steel cube that contained
it, and knocked the guards out of its way
with one swipe of its unnaturally long arms,
sending them careening into a nearby wall.
Fortunately for them, SCP-096 only knocked
them unconscious.
It didn't stop to harm them further, as it
had a more important goal in mind: Find the
person who had seen its face, and destroy
them.
As the alarm blared,
signifying a high-threat-level
containment breach, SCP-096 loped down the
hall toward Dr. Bonita in SCP-914's room.
Dr. Gears had not spotted Dr. Bonita's grave
mistake, and had no idea what had triggered
the alarm he was hearing.
He stepped away from the observation window,
turning his attention to the crisis that was
clearly happening somewhere else in the facility.
Meanwhile, Dr. Bonita was panicking.
She saw her life flash before her eyes, the
certainty of impending doom that was coming
for her, and coming fast, all because of one
brief error in judgment.
What could she do?
There was nowhere to hide, no way she could
run away fast enough, unless...
If she managed to lure 096 into the intake
booth, and start the machine while the creature
was inside, maybe it would transform into
something less intent on tearing her limb
from limb?
It was a risky move, and one that could jeopardize
her position at the Foundation, but she couldn't
very well keep her job if she was dead, so
it seemed like it just might be worth a shot.
A primal roar of agony and fury interrupted
her thoughts, and she knew that SCP-096 was
moments away from breaking down the door and
getting its hands on her.
She would have to move fast.
With the screech and grind of metal on metal,
SCP-096 wrenched the door off its hinges and
barreled into the room.
In its search for the person who had seen
its face, it ran toward the silhouette of
Dr. Bonita, standing just at the entrance
to the intake booth.
She tucked and rolled out of the way, just
as the monster entered the booth.
The door automatically slid shut behind it,
and, as SCP-096 rattled the door and tried
to free itself, she turned the knob to "Very
Fine" with every ounce of strength and speed
she had.
There was the ding of a small bell, and the
machine whirred to life as the objects inside
were refined.
Dr. Bonita has no idea what would be waiting
for her in the Output Booth, but she could
only hope that her last-ditch effort had managed
to save her life.
In the fog of panic, she briefly felt an itch
of scientific curiosity, too.
What would become of a being like SCP-096
in a machine as strange and wonderful as SCP-914?
What would the addition of the statue do to
it?
As the door to the Outtake Booth slid open,
steam pouring out, it appeared her questions
would soon be answered.
Cautiously, in spite of herself, Dr. Bonita
called out: "Hello?"
No one answered, but she heard the sound of
footsteps, slow and careful, as a figure emerged
from the mist.
She covered her mouth in shock, her eyes wide.
"Dear God..."
She whispered in awe.
Standing in front of her, with pale, smooth
skin and the same imposing stature, was the
most beautiful man she had ever seen.
Wide dark eyes shone under thick, sculpted
eyebrows.
Under the eyes, an aquiline nose, full pouty
lips, a strong, sharp jawline.
His head was topped with a tangle of lustrous
dark curls.
It was the kind of hair she had only seen
flowing in the wind on the covers of the romance
novels she wanted desperately to buy, but
was too embarrassed to be seen purchasing.
His physique was, well, statuesque, like the
build of the very Michelangelo sculpture she
had placed into the machine just moments ago.
There was no other way to say it: he was handsome
- Despite still being a little lanky, and
nine feet tall.
He peered at her curiously, towering over
her in a way that had been terrifying in his
former shape, but now made her heart skip
a beat in an entirely different way.
"Hi..."
Was all she could think to say.
Was she blushing?
She shook her head, snapping herself out of
it.
She was a scientist, dammit!
Not some giddy school girl passing notes in
class.
This was an incredible achievement, something
she would need to study thoroughly.
And she very much wanted to
study him thoroughly...No!
No time for that.
She needed to write up a report, to inform
her superiors, to try her best not to lose
her job over this.
She had to remain professional.
"Hi," the man that had once been, or perhaps
still was, SCP-096 spoke.
"Oh!
You can talk!"
Dr. Bonita laughed in surprise.
The man's brow furrowed.
His newfound ability to speak was a surprise
to him too, it seemed.
"Yes.
I can.
What...happened to me?" he asked, stumbling
over his words slightly, getting used to the
feeling of them.
"You ran into the machine..."
She gestured to SCP-914.
"I'm not exactly sure, to be honest.
But you're...very different not."
He nodded.
"I feel different.
I feel...calm."
He sighed, the relief plain on his face, before
a shadow of sadness fell over him.
"I don't think I have to hurt anymore.
I'm...I'm sorry.
For what I did before."
Dr. Bonita didn't know what to say.
How do you respond when something you've been
studying from afar, been horrified and fascinated
by in equal measure, looks at you with a new,
beautiful face and apologizes for all of the
harm it caused?
This whole experience was so surreal that
she might think she was dreaming if she didn't
work at a place that was one long waking dream,
or nightmare depending on the day.
"Dr. Bonita?
There's been a containment breach, are you
alright?"
Dr. Gears had returned to the room, taking
in the sight of the destruction left in 096's
wake.
"I'm fine..."
She called to him, and he followed her voice
into the room, then stopped at the sight of
the transformed anomaly.
"Hm.
I don't have time for whatever this is.
I trust you'll handle it?"
Dr. Gears took a long sip of his coffee, and,
taking Dr. Bonita's shocked
silence as a confirmation,
had a leisurely stroll back to his office.
A few moments later, the guards responsible
for containing SCP-096 arrived on the scene,
expecting to see carnage and find a docile
SCP-096 crouched over a lifeless body, but
instead they found the same truly bizarre
sight that Dr. Gears had shrugged off, and
Dr. Bonita was still doing her best to process.
They entered the room with their weapons drawn,
but quickly lowered them, scratching their
heads in confusion instead, before radioing
their supervisors and asking
for further instructions.
Responses from various Foundation staff who
caught a glimpse of SCP-096's bold new look
included "Huh, would you look at that?"
"Who's that guy?
He's WHAT?!"
and, in the words of Dr. Jack Bright, "Oh
NO, he's HOT!"
Dr. Bright also proposed making the new SCP-096
a tiktok account and YouTube channel, seeking
modeling representation for him, or selling
a novelty calendar filled with pictures of
096 in various costumes.
These would be, in his words, "Excellent ways
to increase revenue for the Foundation.
So really you're the weird ones for thinking
my ideas are weird."
Dr. Bright was asked to leave SCP-096 alone,
and stop trying to take his headshot.
In the days that followed the incident with
SCP-914, the SCP Foundation was at a loss
about what to do with this new, seemingly
harmless version of SCP-096.
Dozens of D-Class were brought in to look
at his face, and see if the entity would still
enter one of his rage states after a few days
of getting used to his new form, but he never
did.
No screaming, no swallowing people whole,
nothing more than a polite, if somewhat shy,
greeting, and a courteous "How are you doing
today?"
The D-Classes were relieved, but confused
about being pulled from their cells just to
stare at some random handsome man.
Dr. Clef suggested dissecting SCP-096, to
see what his new body looked like on the inside.
This request was denied.
Several interviews were conducted to evaluate
SCP-096's mental and emotional state.
Now that the anomaly was capable of coherent
speech, it was much simpler to evaluate the
potential threat level he might pose.
Every researcher who spoke with him came to
the same conclusion: gone was the danger of
the old SCP-096.
He had not just become beautiful in a classical,
superficial sense, but he had become beautiful
on the inside as well.
Interviewers reported a warm, friendly demeanor,
a talent for engaging in conversation once
he was made to feel comfortable, and a sincere
interest in the thoughts, opinions, and feelings
of those he spoke with.
There was only one thing left to do, to make
sure that SCP-096 had really changed from
something deadly to something almost resembling
an ordinary person.
A photograph of SCP-096's face, of its original
face, was removed from a secure vault by a
D-Class.
Then, the D-Class was sent into a room with
SCP-096, and instructed to place the photograph
on the table.
SCP-096 looked down at what had once been
his face, and his eyes filled with tears.
A soft, broken sob left his lips, and he wrapped
his arms around himself, hunching over as
if in physical pain.
Outside the room, guards prepared to handle
things if 096 began to attack.
Instead, he wiped his tears, took a deep,
shuddering breath, and looked at the D-Class
with a somber expression.
He picked up the photograph of the table,
and tore it in half, as he finally summoned
the strength to speak.
"Please...get rid of these.
That's not who I am anymore."
At Dr. Bonita's strong insistence, backed
up by the conclusions of the research staff
who interviewed SCP-096, a reevaluation of
the entity's containment measures was ordered.
It seemed cruel, and an unnecessary waste
of resources, to keep 096 trapped in a steel
cube in its current form.
He would be moved to a
standard humanoid containment
cell, and treated as well as other safe-class
anomalies provided with books, films, food
and drink upon request, and other comforts.
Of course, the O5 council insisted on evaluating
the entity before any of these changes could
be approved.
Dressed in a specially tailored suit, provided
by Dr. Bonita, SCP-096 appeared before the
council to present his case.
"I know that I may not have the best record
at the Foundation.
I've done a lot of damage over the years.
Though, let's be honest, you all aren't exactly
innocent either.
Sorry, that was an attempt at a joke.
I'm still very new to talking.
All I can say is, please consider giving me
another chance to make a real life here, to
make this place my home.
Thank you for your time."
What SCP-096 didn't know is that the O5 Council
was so flabbergasted by the sight of his new
face that they didn't retain a single word
he said.
They had all given their official approval
before he even finished his short presentation.
Before long, SCP-096 was moved out of his
steel cube and into a new containment chamber
that resembled a mid-range studio apartment
complete with a bed, a kitchenette, a television,
and a table and chairs.
He was provided access to all major streaming
platforms, as well as a large stack of books
to help him develop his grasp of culture and
language after so very long being isolated
from human society.
Though he wasn't exactly human, he was determined
to act like it.
Word quickly spread around the Foundation
site, and humans and anomalies alike flocked
to SCP-096's new home to visit him, and see
the miraculous transformation for themselves.
SCP-999 was the first to come and see the
new and improved 096, chirping excitedly as
it oozed into his room.
He pet the slime gently, his face breaking
into a warm smile as its euphoric effect washed
over him.
The slime became so excited at meeting this
new friend, someone it had known as a source
of sadness and hurt for so long, that it tackled
him to the ground and tickled him for several
minutes, 096 laughing uproariously all the
while.
SCP-343 stopped by to give 096 his blessing
and wish him well in this new chapter of his
life.
A few days later, SCP-507 popped back into
the Site and wanted to see the changes for
himself.
He was thoroughly impressed, though privately
confessed to missing SCP-096's more monstrous
form, which reminded him of some of his favorite
cryptids.
There was one anomaly that was not thrilled
with the appearance of SCP-096, however.
SCP-056 was furious upon hearing about the
new beautiful man that everyone just couldn't
shut up about.
It demanded a chance to speak to SCP-096,
and to tell him that "This place isn't big
enough for the both of us.
I'm the fairest of them all, you sniveling
little worm!"
But the request was denied.
SCP-056 sulked about it for several weeks.
Meanwhile, Dr. Bonita was still intent on
getting to know SCP-096 better.
During previous testing with SCP-978, the
Desire Camera, a photo taken of SCP-096 revealed
that his greatest desire was to disappear.
Curious about what the results would be now,
Dr. Bonita received permission to take another
picture of SCP-096.
She snapped the photo while 096 was sitting
in a chair in his new containment chamber,
looking directly at the camera.
When the photo developed, the result was simple:
Everything in the picture was exactly the
same, with one exception.
Dr. Bonita was pictured sitting next to SCP-096,
her hand clasped in his.
Both were smiling soft, contented smiles.
When she showed him the photograph, he smiled
at her and shook his head.
"It really is an amazing camera."
She flushed.
"Doctor...before you go, could I ask your
name?"
Dr. Bonita smiled, and nodded.
"It's Isabelle.
What should I call you?"
SCP-096 paused thoughtfully for a moment.
He was giving himself a name for the very
first time, allowing himself an identity other
than a strange, hollow, pale thing that existed
to cry, and suffer, and hurt.
Finally, he answered her: "Call me David."
Dr. Dan anxiously paced his cell.
It was the only way he’d been able to occupy
himself for the past six months, save for
poring through files and, when he was lucky,
being able to oversee another failed termination
attempt.
He only stopped pacing when, for a brief and
horrible moment, he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing in
its big, metal cube at this very moment.
That horrible creature that he’d thrown
away his life for a futile shot at killing.
Perhaps the whole thing had been a fool’s
errand.
After all, he was formerly a researcher under
the employ of the SCP Foundation.
Secure, Contain, Protect.
They had truly sadistic beasts like SCP-106,
the nightmarish Old Man, and SCP-352, Baba
Yaga, in containment cells, and there were
no plans to terminate either of them.
They weren’t the Global Occult Coalition,
for 343’s sake.
Why did Dr. Dan even want to terminate SCP-096
in the first place?
He’d tried to explain it to them again and
again, but his pleas had fallen on deaf ears.
In his mind, the impetus for destroying the
Shy Guy was terrifyingly clear.
It was a monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face, even a photograph
of it, even a tiny collection of pixels.
When its rage state was induced, it seemed
that nothing would stop it.
It would have an intuitive psychic link to
its victim, charge at them at breakneck speed,
and only find its zen again once all of them
were dead.
And if a picture of SCP-096 was leaked onto
the Internet, it would cause a chain reaction
that triggered an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario.
There were plenty of creatures and entities
that the Foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse,
but to him, 096 was the most realistic.
It preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every human
heart.
The same drive to simply Know that led to
the creation of the SCP Foundation would be
humanity’s doom in the face of an SCP-096
outbreak, and if such a thing happened, the
Foundation would need to break the Masquerade
of secrecy to have any hope of saving humanity.
In his many feverish nightmares, Dr. Dan had
seen it all so clearly.
The first photographs of SCP-096’s face
would be leaked online.
Perhaps a few hundred people across the globe
would look, in disparate enough locations
that it would be almost impossible for the
Foundation to detect and save all of them
as SCP-096 went on its bloody rampage.
Of course, as the image proliferated, as images
on the internet do, the purview of 096’s
violence would only grow.
People across the nation would start to take
notice.
And soon after that, across the world.
“Mysterious creature causing mass casualties”
would be the headline on every news desk,
because why would anybody want to talk about
anything else?
Perhaps some foolish reporters would take
video footage of the creature.
Everyone has a phone these
days with high-definition
cameras, pictures would be taken and posted.
More and more and more of it would flood the
internet.
Too many simultaneous moles for even the SCP
Foundation to whack.
The news would spread.
Panic and hysteria would spread.
People wouldn’t even know what’s triggering
all this horror if the Foundation didn’t
go public and tell them that it was the pictures
that was killing everyone.
And by then, wouldn’t it already be too
late?
The antidote to fear is knowledge.
It’s why, when anything goes wrong, we’re
refreshing timelines and feeds and news websites
for any kind of information.
And if you were told an unstoppable monster
was killing scores of people and might be
coming to a neighborhood near you sometime
soon, wouldn’t you want a good look at it?
Wouldn’t you want to know your enemy, having
no idea that the mere act of knowing was what
sealed your horrible fate?
By Dr. Dan’s bleak estimations, if only
several million people died as a result of
this kind of scenario, it could be considered
a positive outcome.
He’d seen it all.
But no matter how many
times he tried to articulate
this to his superiors, he wasn’t listened
to.
They didn’t take him or the threat that
SCP-096 posed seriously.
Every time he warned of the apocalyptic potential
of SCP-096, he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles.
It was why he needed to give those naysayers
a demonstration.
It was why a certain photograph needed to
show up in the home of a certain mountaineer.
It’s why all those people had to die.
There was no other way.
The deaths of the civilians and the researchers
and the Mobile Task Force members were, of
course, regrettable, but it was the only way
to prevent the deaths of so many more.
They gave him what he wanted: Permission to
put this gangly time bomb in the ground, even
if the beast’s death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the very
employers who authorized him.
The world was full of funny little ironies
like that.
Another one is that, even though Dr. Dan now
had the authorization and funding to terminate
SCP-096, he was discovering that he lacked
another important factor: The capability.
They’d tried incinerating it.
Exposing it to massive amounts of radiation.
Exposing it to an insane degree of kinetic
trauma - the equivalent of being hit by an
out-of-control bullet train.
They’d tested every kind of experimental,
off-the-books weaponry they had access to
through various research projects.
Proton blasts.
Lasers.
High-intensity energy beams.
Nothing.
Even when they fried off every scrap of flesh
on the monster’s body, its unbreakable skeleton
still remained, and in what seemed like no
time at all, it’d be back in action.
Its very existence seemed to mock him.
A guard opened his cell door, staring disdainfully
at the disgraced researcher.
That same guard had slammed his head against
a wall a month earlier.
One of his friends had apparently been killed
in the legendary 096 containment breach that
set this whole sordid thing in motion.
“Up and at ‘em, scumbag,” he said in
a gruff, surly voice, training a handgun on
the Doctor he knew wouldn’t fight back.
“They need you in test chamber six.”
Dr. Dan allowed himself a small grin.
Imperceptible to the guard who clearly hated
his guts.
They’d approved his 096 Vs 682 cross test.
Marvelous.
To all the others, it would seem like just
one more entry in a long line of 682 cross
tests.
He thought it darkly funny - In his eyes,
the Foundation had no hope of ever killing
SCP-682.
Its defining quality was being impossible
to kill, and it didn’t present nearly the
threat to the entire world that 096 posed.
Their futile attempts to murder the lizard
were little more than a money sink to justify
the site’s exorbitant funding.
But perhaps he could turn this to his benefit.
Maybe SCP-682 would hold the secret to actually
killing off his nemesis...
Within 30 hours, Dr. Dan had his disappointing
answer.
Both anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other, and Dr. Dan did take
a kind of sick amusement in the mental trauma
that SCP-682 had induced in 096, but ultimately
it was all for nothing.
682 had skinned 096 alive and melted off its
flesh with acid, but once
again, that indestructible
skeleton stood firm.
This had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident.
The 27th failed termination attempt, Dr. Dan
mentally corrected himself.
096’s skeleton kept defeating them - Even
their most ardent attempts to penetrate the
bones and destroy the creature within had
failed.
During a previous attempt, they’d tried
to access the brain by putting a diamond-hard
drill into its eye sockets.
Of course, it was the drill that actually
broke, much to Dr. Dan’s seemingly tireless
frustration.
Needless to say, in the debriefing interview
with Dr. Carver, a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague, he wasn’t
in high spirits.
If he managed to kill this thing, then he
would always be the hero who made a terrible
sacrifice in order to save many more lives.
If he didn’t kill 096, he was little more
than the monster who murdered all those innocent
people for nothing.
Though you’d never hear him say it out loud.
If it wasn’t for that damnable indestructible
skeleton, this monster would be long dead
already.
If only there was some way to break the creature’s
bones...
That’s when it hit him: SCP-173.
The Sculpture.
A Site-19 icon often overlooked because of
its more “silent but deadly” style, but
undeniably one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there.
It had racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at Site-19 in
1993, one broken neck at a time, and it’s
one of the few creatures out there that even
the Hard to Destroy Reptile himself is utterly
terrified of.
Perhaps a monster that practically had a PhD
in breaking bones would be the ideal candidate
to vandalize the Shy Guy’s vertebrae.
Once his proposal was greenlit for initial
testing, Dr. Dan arranged for the Shy Guy
- with a bag over his head, of course - to
be brought into a testing chamber with the
ever-stoic SCP-173.
When all of the researchers and guards were
safely outside, all it took was a single blink
to make all of Dr. Dan’s darkest dreams
come true.
In the nanoseconds his eyes were closed, he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the world:
A loud, fleshy crunch, and a pained howl from
096.
He opened his eyes to an equally wondrous
sight: 096 doubled over at an unnatural angle,
its spine snapped between the fourth and fifth
vertebrae, spinal fluid
leaking down the creature’s
flank.
That freaky little sculpture had done it.
It had actually damaged the integrity of the
Shy Guy’s skeleton.
It was at that moment that Dr. Dan knew he
could kill this thing.
Admittedly, there was a containment breach
shortly after that when the bag slipped off
of 096’s head and it charged through the
nearby steel wall, killing multiple people
before being subdued and recontained.
But when it comes to projects involving Dr.
Dan, a mere handful of innocent people being
killed sits comfortably within the acceptable
margin of error.
A day later, Dr. Dan was standing before a
crowded boardroom, with agents, researchers,
and even a few members of the O5 Council in
attendance.
He explained his findings to them, and the
fact that, even more importantly, they may
have a way to bring the wretched existence
of 096 to an absolute halt.
His plans were approved.
Not long after, he was putting them into motion.
Dr. Dan was surrounded by researchers and
heavily armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift. 096 was
there, still bagged.
Off to the side was a giant tub of hydrofluoric
acid connected to a hose and injector attachment.
If this didn’t work, nothing would.
Everyone stood back in a safe zone as 173
was released to do its thing.
Crunch.
Just like the previous time, 096’s spine
had been successfully snapped.
Spinal fluid dribbled down its skin.
Everyone had rushed into the chamber - One
group kept 173 isolated with their stares.
The other, headed by Dr. Dan, prepared the
acid injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096’s spine.
As the acid was pumped by the gallon into
096’s bones, the creature let out the most
horrifying wail.
It kicked and bucked as more acid was pumped
in, melting those indestructible bones from
within.
The creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked, melting the bag off of its own head.
Some panicked and averted their gaze.
Dr. Dan didn’t.
He stared directly at the creature’s face
for the first time as it melted in front of
him with nothing short of pure elation.
Had he won?
Had he actually won?
The creature let out a gurgling shriek and
the guards opened fire.
Their bullets splattered into the monster’s
melting flesh and bones as it hollered and
shrieked.
They didn’t let up, firing up and down its
body, spraying it with white-hot lead.
It began to melt and bubble away, expanding
into a great, gruesome puddle on the floor
beneath them.
Dr. Dan laughed like a madman.
Even as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling, greasy mess,
bubbling with chemical life, he just kept
laughing.
Even though he knew the death of 096 meant
an equally swift death of his own, it didn’t
matter.
It had all been for something.
The world was saved.
It was over.
He’d finally won.
A lot of us wish we could travel the multiverse,
pay a visit to another world and see all the ways
in which it differs from this dimension that we
call home. Maybe there’s a decision that you made
that altered the course of your entire life –
what college you went to, asking somebody out,
accepting a job over pursuing a passion.
The question of ‘what if’ might have kept
you wondering what your life could have
looked like if you picked the other path.
Surely it would save you all that wondering and be
so much easier just to go and find out. Imagine if
you could simply pick a universe where you chose
differently, then take a quick jaunt over there to
see how things turned out for your other self.
But what if you couldn’t choose?
Never mind whatever that decision was; what if
you couldn’t pick where in the infinite multiverse
you ended up? If traveling from world to world
was as random, unpredictable, and instinctive
as a sneeze, what then? One moment you’re safe at
home, surrounded by everything you know. It might
not be perfect, but at least it's familiar. The
next thing you know, with a blink of your eyes,
you’re standing in a world that maybe looks
similar, but giant bees are the dominant species
instead of humans. Or the world is overrun
by spiders, or everyone is made out of paint.
Needless to say, you’d be at
least a little disorientated,
at worst absolutely terrified for your life.
That pretty much sums up the experience of
SCP-507, also known as the Reluctant Dimension
Hopper. From the outside, he looks to be a
mostly normal human man, with blonde hair,
green eyes; nothing all that remarkable
about him of note save for him having a somewhat
unplaceable accent. Despite having a legal name,
SCP-507 will try to squeeze what little enjoyment
he can out of introducing himself by a different
nickname to everyone he meets; previous favorites
have included Tommy, Steve, Bruto, Guy, Houdini,
and Grabnok the Destroyer. We’ll stick with Tommy.
The sole most intriguing thing about Tommy is
that, through a process that happens
completely without his control,
he can spontaneously disappear, only to reappear
after an unspecified amount of time later. During
that time, SCP-507 will have been in a completely
different universe to our own. This can happen at
any time of day or night – and usually at
the most inconvenient moments; including
while Tommy is in the middle of a conversation,
trying to sleep, or using the… ‘facilities.’
He had no control over when it happens, however,
he'll always arrive in an alternate universe in
the same geographical spot he was in while in
ours. If he moves around in a parallel world,
then when he returns, he will have relocated to
the corresponding place back in this universe.
And that’s when disaster struck.
Alarms were blaring, declaring to all staff
on-site that there had been a containment breach
in one of the anomaly’s holding cells. All hands
were on deck, and security teams were converging,
dashing through the corridors. This was the second
alert today, at first SCP-507 had vanished on one
of his unplanned little excursions, but now it
seemed that another SCP was trying to do the same.
Dazed, trying to reorientate himself, Tommy rested
against a nearby wall. His head was spinning,
and he knew it would for a few more seconds.
He was in a cell, similar to the one he’d just
been in while in another universe. Except here,
back home, there was a key difference: The cell
was occupied. As soon as his vision cleared,
Tommy looked up at the only other creature in the
room with him. It was a tall, wiry humanoid shape,
completely hairless with pale skin, white eyes,
and a large, gaping jaw. Turning to face him,
Tommy instantly recognized the creature from
a description he’d been read by a Foundation
researcher: it was SCP-096.
Uh oh, spaghetti-o’s.
Realizing its face was being observed, the Shy Guy
started screeching, first an uncontrollable wail
of distress that quickly gave way to a guttural,
animalistic roar of anger. It covered its face,
babbling to itself as Tommy backed away,
banging his hand against the sealed wall
of 096’s cell. Then, the creature turned towards
him, and lunged, racing across the room to where
SCP-507 was trapped. All he could do was close
his eyes tight and think about running away…
Tommy could feel a headache brewing in his skull,
and caught traces of a familiar flash through his
closed eyelids. He gently opened them back up.
It had happened again, maybe for the first time
ever at a moment when he actually needed to get
away. Staggering to his feet, Tommy looked around.
He was in the cell still, or rather, another
version of it in a different universe yet again.
Knowing that he wouldn’t be able to
predict when he would next displace,
he didn’t want to reappear right back where he
had started, with SCP-096 poised to kill him. So,
relocating was top priority. Fortunately, the
cell actually had a door in this universe,
and that door wasn’t locked. In fact, none
of the doors were locked or even guarded,
and the Foundation facility, while looking more
or less the same, was completely abandoned. It
almost looked like it had never even been used.
Stepping out of the entrance, Tommy trekked
his way towards the city. He knew it was a short
hike away, and by the time he could feel blisters
forming on his feet, he was close enough that it
didn’t matter. Within another few short steps,
he was standing among the tall buildings and
surprisingly empty streets. One of the first
things that struck Tommy about this universe
was that there were hardly any people around
outside. On top of that, the roads were devoid
of cars. Everything around was so quiet; the air
was still and clean when he breathed it in.
The sound of footsteps against the pavement
immediately caught Tommy’s attention, the
first sign of anyone else around other than
him. Racing towards the noise of another
person, Tommy turned a corner and bumped
straight into an old man in a long coat, who had
clearly been in a hurry, and quickly revealed he
didn’t have the best temperament either.
“Watch where you’re going!” he shouted,
caught off-guard by the sight of another person
put on the streets. “What in the hell are
you playing at, sneaking up on me like that?
You trying to get yourself killed out here?”
“Oh, definitely not!” Tommy said, climbing back
to his feet, hands held out apologetically.
“I’m so sorry mister, I was just-”
“You got a death wish or something,
kid?” the old man demanded, marching past him.
“No!” SCP-507 protested, chasing after the
man. “Wait, what makes you say that?”
“As if you don’t know,” he scoffed. “Look
around you, look up at the sky! There’s a storm
about to hit, any second now, it’s a-coming. And
if you don’t get inside, you’re a goner.”
“What could be so dangerous about
a thunderstorm?” Tommy asked.
The old man stared back at him with a look
of confusion on his wizened face, looking at Tommy
like he had just said something utterly bizarre.
“What the hell’s a thunderstorm?” the man asked.
Feeling equally confused, Tommy craned his neck
up towards the sky. Looming above were a swirling
mass of clouds, the kind anyone would expect to
be accompanied by severe winds, and the deafening
boom of thunder. But the wind was still, and there
was nothing but silence. Until a choking, gurgling
sound came from somewhere behind Tommy’s back.
He spun back around to see the tall, wiry frame
of SCP-096, its long fingers gripping tightly
around the old man’s throat. It had followed
Tommy, and he knew that anyone who saw its face,
even in a picture, would find themselves chased
down on foot by the creature. But he had no idea
the Shy Guy could travel between dimensions.
He’d foolishly allowed himself to think that he
was safe, out of the monster’s reach, but now it
seemed to be showing him that the opposite was
true. It hoisted the helpless old man upwards
by his neck, his shoes barely able to graze
the pavement as his legs flailed, eyes rolling
back as the Shy Guy clamped his throat shut.
The very second Tommy turned to run, the clouds
churned above and, without so much as a warning,
the storm hit. Something wasn’t right, Tommy
could feel his feet lifting off the ground,
immediately panicking as he thought SCP-096
had grabbed him. But, looking over his shoulder
showed the creature was still a few feet behind,
and starting to gently float up off the ground
too. Instinctively, Tommy’s legs started thrashing
around, trying to gain a solid footing. Instead,
all his urgent motions did was cause him to
start spinning uncontrollably, as the gravity
storm lifted him higher and higher into the air.
Spinning around as he was taken further upwards,
Tommy caught sight of SCP-096. The Shy Guy
was staying still, as if it was still in
control of its body’s motion while he was
wildly flipping over himself. The tall,
pale creature drifted closer to the side of
a nearby building, with Tommy barely able to
reach the top of the streetlights as he was pulled
further away from the safety of having both his
feet on the ground. Just as he saw SCP-096 push
itself off the edge of the building, drifting
straight through the air towards him, Tommy shut
his eyes again and prayed he’d displace again.
Sure enough, a flash of light came bursting
out in time with another headache. Suddenly,
he had appeared in the exact same
spot in another universe. However,
here there was no gravity storm in progress
here. In fact, no such phenomena existed,
the laws of physics were much more in keeping with
those in Tommy’s home, our universe. Of course,
that would be more reassuring if he wasn’t already
several feet up in the air. The second he arrived,
Tommy started plummeting back down to
Earth, screaming as he felt himself falling,
keeping his eyes screwed shut as he dared not look
at the ground he was currently hurtling towards.
His plummet was broken by something, not
particularly soft. Whatever it was seemed
to tower high enough that Tommy only picked up
a few bruises as he hit it. But the fall didn’t
stop instantly, instead, he kept on toppling
through whatever he had landed on. It was some
kind of mass, piled up almost as tall as a
building, a collection of lots of… things,
that were all brushing past Tommy the more
he fell. He hadn’t yet stopped for long
enough to recognize the sensations, that
is, until he landed with a painful thud.
Slowly opening his eyes back up, Tommy could
barely see anything in front of him. He was
so deep in the mass that the pile was blocking
out the sunlight, with only a few beams bleeding
through the gaps, but barely enough to give
him a clear view of where he was. Tommy tried
to crawl forward, squeezed between the heavy
things around him, pushing though whatever
tiny little crevice he could find. As he did,
the weight of the pile shifted around him,
and he was worried that any moment he would move
the wrong part of it, bringing the whole structure
collapsing down on top of him like a toppled jenga
tower, only big enough to crush him to death.
He forced himself not to think about exactly what
the pile was made of either. It was already long
past the point where Tommy recognized what each…
thing felt like. Plus, there was the added stench,
something – or lots of somethings – rotting and
producing a stomach-turning odor as it decayed.
Even when you’re trying not to look, it can be
hard to mistake the feeling of a hand, an arm,
cold skin against his. The light from beyond the
pyramid was getting closer, he could see it was
starting to illuminate more of his surroundings
the close her crawled to the perimeter. Sure,
he could have very easily used the torch
the Foundation let him keep with him. But
Tommy wasn’t quite ready to see what he was
crawling through yet, intentionally shutting
his eyes and opting instead to follow the
faint glow and distant warmth of the sun.
Breaching the outer side of the pile, Tommy gulped
down lungfuls of air. It barely tasted or smelled
that much cleaner than the air within the mass,
but at least he was free. Clawing himself out and
along the ground, he finally, carefully, stood up,
still keeping both eyes screwed shut. Part of him
really didn’t want to take a look around this
new dimension, maybe if he waited long enough,
he would displace again and end up somewhere with
less… decomposing. But then he remembered SCP-096
was still after him, and he had no idea how
to escape it. He needed to try and figure out
what he was going to do, and the only way to
do that… was to look around at where he was.
Lifting his eyelids, the different sized masses
of all shades, shapes and sizes lay before him.
Each one was coated in one unifying color,
all of them slick with the crimson of blood
against skin. Tommy could feel the urge to
throw up quickly shooting up from the pit
of his stomach towards his throat as he looked
at the massive pile of bodies in front of him.
It was enormous, there were so many dead people
all laying on top of one another that the pile
reached up as tall as office buildings. And
the pile that he had fallen into and crawled
his way out of wasn’t the only one either. As
far as the eye could see, everyone was dead.
Feeling a heavy sob at the back of his throat,
Tommy swallowed it when he heard another sound
above the low buzzing of flies over the human
carcasses. Someone… something else was crying
nearby, and the moment he turned around, the
familiar figure caught Tommy’s eye. Even without
being the only other living thing around for
miles, the Shy Guy still stood out clear as
day. Its distress at finding itself in this
horrible dimension briefly mirrored Tommy’s own,
until it restablished its psychic link
with its victim and gave chase once more.
SCP-096 started dashing towards SCP-507. For
a split second, he thought about just letting
it catch him; what difference would it make in a
place like this? But then, the hallucinations of
bright colors and a stinging deep within his skull
hit Tommy. And just like that, he was gone again.
It was nighttime in the next dimension Tommy
arrived in. The cold air and dim light of the
street were enough to give that away. But at
least he was away from that last world filled
with discarded and unburied piles of corpses,
he thought to himself. Surely, he couldn’t
possibly be anywhere worse than that now…
The first sight that Tommy was met with
was a huge, white LCD screen, big enough
to cover the entire side of one of the
skyscrapers facing him. Emblazoned against
the bright white glow was a familiar symbol,
a circle with three arrows crossing its outline
and pointing towards its center. Around that was
a thin frame, another circle, this one with three
protruding rectangles around the circumference,
in line with the arrow tails. Thick lettered text
appeared on the screen too, beneath the emblem,
boldly proclaiming that anyone reading
it should ‘Submit. Comply. Persevere.’
Tommy blinked in disbelief, looking around.
There was hardly anyone else around,
save for a few people staring at him; had they
seen him appear? Or was it just because he was
dressed so differently to them? Each of
them had on a grimy pair of overalls,
sporting more of that same symbol on the chest
and across the back. Every wall of every nearby
building was overfilled with posters featuring
matching imagery, each one posing different
questions in the same unforgiving, accusatory
text against its clinical white background.
One poster read ‘Could you be anomalous?
Submit for testing today.’ Another had the
following notice: ‘Curfew still in effect, 10am
to 8am the following morning. All citizens must
Comply.’ And one more touted that ‘Only through
Persevering will we all continue to thrive.’
Each of them was signed with the same name and
logo to match, the organization that Tommy had
come to put some amount of trust in, even though
they weren’t always clear with him. But he knew
they weren’t the bad guys, or at least, the
version that existed in his universe didn’t
seem to be too bad. They had questionable
methods, but they weren’t evil… weren’t this.
“By order of the SCP Foundation!” A loud,
militaristic voice barked from behind Tommy. “Get
down on your knees with your hands behind your
head. You will surrender any anomalous technology
and declare any memetic effects or cognito
hazardous abilities before we approach you.”
Tommy looked over his shoulder, met with
the barrels of several automatic weapons
that were now being trained on him. Instantly
he threw his hands in the air, terrified that
this alternate SCP Foundation might be far more
trigger-happy than the version of them he was
used to. From the look at the oppressive text
on the huge screen, the propaganda posters and
the matching uniforms ordinary people seemed
forced to wear, this Foundation seemed to be
far more ruthless. They had transformed from
a secretive organization into a full-blown
authoritarian regime, maybe even in control
of the entire world, ruling with an iron fist.
“On your knees!” the commander of
the Mobile Task Force shouted again.
The aggression in his voice, as well
as the several laser pointers from
his men’s’ guns that were hovering over his
chest, prompted Tommy to do as he was told.
“Do you have anything to declare before
we approach?” the MTF leader barked.
“N-no!” Tommy stammered before realizing that
was probably an inadvisable answer. “I mean,
yes! I’m… I’m SCP-507, but that number
might refer to someone different here. Look,
what I’m saying is, this isn’t my dimension,
okay? I have a condition that sends me to
different universes at random, I can’t
control it, it just happens. Please,
for the love of god, don’t shoot!”
“Better radio into command,” the team
leader told one of his subordinates. “Tell
them to run that number against the Archives,
then inform Lord Adjudicator Clef that
we may have a containment breach.”
Overhearing what they were saying instantly
reminded Tommy that he was still being chased.
“Wait,” he called to the elite operatives.
“There’s something else you need to know!”
“What’s that, 507?” the commander
sighed, lacking the patience for this.
“There’s another anomaly after me!” Tommy
explained hurriedly. “I don’t know how long
it’ll take to get here, just that when it
does… it’ll kill everyone to get at me.”
“I’ve heard enough, troopers take
him away,” the commander grunted.
Two of the MTF team rushed up to Tommy and
grappled either of his arms, not letting
go despite his protests. They started dragging
him towards their armored vehicle, looking like
Tommy was about to spend the foreseeable future
in the clutches of one of the worst versions
of the Foundation. That is, until a tall, pale
creature stepped out from behind the transport.
The MTFs were instantly frenzied, and yells of
another anomalous contact were quickly drowned
out by the noise of gunfire. All the while, the
Shy Guy was casually moving between the amassed
troops, gripping their heads, twisting them all
the way around until a sickening crunch rang out.
Dropped back to the ground, SCP-507 started to
feel another headache coming on, knowing that any
second he’d displace again and end up in another
alternate universe. And for the first time today,
he was okay with that. It was better
for their chase to go on if it meant
that him and the Shy Guy didn’t have to
spend another minute in this universe.
He’s waiting for you in the dark.
He sits, cross-legged, still as a placid lake
and patient as a praying monk six feet deep
in meditation.
He’s been like this for so long.
His body oil-slicked with deadly black grease,
skin ancient and haggard, eyes black and flat
with the kind of calm you only find in crawling
insects and Great White Sharks.
His lipless mouth is stretched across his
jawbone in an ugly, black rictus.
He may be an Old Man, but trust us, he’s
got plenty of new tricks he’d love to show
you.
He sat in the loneliest place in the world:
The deep, dark bowels of an SCP Foundation
containment site, surrounded by a complex
confluence of containment measures: Different
shapes, running liquids, bright lights, the
kind of steel so thick a nuclear weapon would
only leave it scuffed.
All the things that had a tendency to...
Confuse him.
Because that’s all they ever did.
The Old Man laughed to himself, very quietly.
All the people out there are so scared of
him because of one immutable fact: He isn’t
trapped here, he’s just resting.
By virtue of his unique anomalous abilities
- to pass through solids at will and resist
any form of physical damage they can dole
out - there is no way to really contain him
like all the others.
All the SCP Foundation could hope to do was
make leaving inconvenient enough for him to
make his little adventures on the outside
less appealing than just sitting around, doing
nothing.
After all, he had all the time in the world,
and when you always have a “Later”, there’s
a lot less pressure to do anything now.
But like all thinking creatures - And please,
be aware that SCP-106, the wretched, terrifying
Old Man, is very much a thinking creature
- he was subject to occasional boredom.
And when most people are bored, they might
play a video game, watch a few YouTube videos,
or rewatch It’s Always Sunny In Philadelphia
for the fifth time.
But for the Old Man, killing boredom involved...
Well, killing people.
But not just killing people, of course.
Truth be told, for him, killing was really
the least entertaining part of the whole affair.
The screams?
The begging?
The desperate pleas?
Warm tears on shaking cheeks?
Convulsions of pain?
Cold sweats?
Fear so intense it gives way to gibbering
madness?
That dull sheen of dead hope in their eyes
when they then realize that their doom is
inevitable, and that he, their captor, their
torturer, would decide the exact moment they
slipped into the void?
Oh, that was what he lived for - If you could
call what the Old Man did Living.
He cracked his neck and licked his teeth.
Was he salivating?
All those thoughts about pain seemed to have
got him worked up.
He could feel the distant thumping of his
heart.
Old, black blood pumping through the dusty
corridors of his vascular system.
Synapses booming and sparking with excitement
at the thought of plumbing new depths of human
misery, like a scholar of suffering, a pioneer
of pain.
All those silly Foundation drones, with the
audacity to think they’re in control.
He’d teach them to scream again...
Meanwhile, in the control room for the Old
Man’s containment chamber, all hell was
breaking loose.
Monitors on the monster’s vitals were all
spiking: Heart and brain activity peaked,
just as they always did before the Old Man
decided to get active.
Cameras in his containment chamber showed
him rising steadily to his feet, cracking
his joints, limbering up.
His body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate, pooling
around his feet and unleashing squalls of
noxious fumes as it melted into the floor.
Years of Foundation testing, and they still
couldn’t find any material that could withstand
that vile black slop...
As the Old Man began strolling towards the
wall, a containment specialist in the control
room grabbed a nearby phone and sounded the
alarm for the containment breach.
They needed a Mobile Task Force and every
guard on site mobilized to tackle 106 before
he got into the facility proper and started
causing havoc.
They couldn’t risk it escaping, either - The
infamous incident when the Old Man escaped
for a Halloween massacre still haunted the
nightmares of many a staff member.
He had to be stopped - Now!
A small fighting force was quickly armed and
assembled, along with armor
and several high-intensity
portable lights to hopefully slow the monster
down in time for them to grab a D-Class and
set up the femur breaker.
By the time they all reached the hallway they
intended to use as a choke point for the escape,
the Old Man was already half way through the
outer layer of defence, phasing through the
wall with that same terrible, manic grin he
always had when he was about to inflict terrible
violence for the sheer fun of it.
The guards and task force members trained
their lights and weapons on him.
All of them had seen terrible things on the
job - the kind of things that would saddle
almost anyone with a lifetime of trauma - but
almost nothing compared to the horror of direct
engagement during a 106 containment breach.
That terrible old coffin dodger was Hell on
two legs.
When they discovered, to their horror, that
the lights didn’t seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated, they fell back
on Plan B: That B standing for, “Blast the
living hell out of him with everything they
had.”
The personnel opened fire, pumping round after
round into his dark form.
While each gave a loud, meaty splatter, the
Old Man didn’t even flinch.
When he was close enough, all those months
of lethargy gave way to sudden, deadly speed.
In many ways, the Old Man was like a crocodile.
A fierce and intelligent ambush predator who
conserved his energy wisely.
He could seem so deceptively languid that
you could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless.
But when you got within arm’s reach, the
sudden quickness and ferocity would take you
off guard.
And by then, it’s already too late.
Within thirty seconds, the Old Man was the
only thing left alive in that hallway.
All the guards and Task Force operatives sent
to slow him down lay dead, dripping with his
black mucus.
There was silence, save for the quiet fizzing
of the mucus eating into their clothes and
skin.
The Old Man sighed.
How boring.
He’d killed so many people now, it all started
to seem a little...
Samey.
How many screams could you hear before they
all just blended into a single shrill whine?
You can get sick of even your favorite meal
if you eat it too often.
But that didn’t matter.
The Old Man had a different order of business
today: He happened to be inside an SCP Foundation
containment facility, filled with so many
fascinating specimens of non-human entities
that the one they called SCP-106 simply couldn’t
wait to torture.
He’d only met a small portion of the ones
they had contained here, but given what a
fascinating experience his past attack on
his fellow anomalies was, he couldn’t wait
to meet some more.
Meanwhile, the site’s top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second response
to the rogue senior citizen from hell currently
strolling through their high-security containment
facility.
Could they get in contact with other Mobile
Task Forces deployed in the area?
Maybe they could get Hammer Down or Samsara
in on this mess before anything got really
out of hand?
The Old Man seemed more intent on something
this time, they suspected even the femur breaker
might not work in luring him back until he
claimed whatever he deemed to be his prize.
Maybe they should contact the O5 Council...
Security guards were tracking 106’s progress
through the facility via their vast networks
of security cameras.
They warned any research, administration,
and janitorial staff to clear out of his path,
unless they felt like being tortured to death.
He hadn’t dragged anyone into his pocket
dimension yet, so whoever that privilege was
reserved for would probably
be getting a particular
sticky experience.
They could only speculate as to the silent
beast’s intentions.
One guard noticed something.
When cross-referencing 106’s movements with
a map of the facility, they
were able to triangulate
where he was heading: Straight for the containment
chamber of SCP-096.
The guard’s lips curled into a slight smile,
thinking, “If one of you freaks can actually
kill the other, maybe something positive will
come out of this disaster...”
The Old Man was having a stroll down memory
lane.
The time prior, when he broke out of his cell
and decided to hassle his fellow intimates
was certainly eventful - He wound up in the
company of some cantankerous reptile and a
Korean fox woman, an unlikely pair if ever
there was one.
After finding himself in a room with them,
he decided that they should have a little
more privacy, and dragged them back into his
pocket dimension for further fun.
Of course, with two at once, his attention
had been a little split.
They spent as much time tussling with each
other as resisting his attempts to torment
them.
They’d definitely put him through his paces
that day, and he gave far better than he got:
After so many hours of brutal mutilation,
there was barely any of the lizard left, despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly healing
from so many of its wounds.
Still, it was good exercise, even if the results
had been less than satisfying.
If he could get another anomaly alone, though,
he’d be able to take his time, and really
savor the pain he caused.
Oh, that sounded heavenly...
Soon, he came upon an
incredibly strange containment
chamber that quickly caught his eye: It looked
like a huge, metal cube, with no way in or
out.
Not even a seam.
Whatever was trapped in there, the Old Man
thought, it must be something that even the
fools at the SCP Foundation really, truly
wanted nothing to do with.
But even more so than the strange sight, it
was the sound that drew the Old Man in, tempting
him like a siren song.
It was weeping.
A soft, sobbing keen that betrayed a bottomless
well of misery.
Whatever was making that crying sound had
known true despair.
Or, whatever passes for true despair before
you’ve had a close encounter with the Old
Man in his pocket dimension.
The Old Man grinned, and thought, “Oh, sonny,
I’ll give you something to really cry about...”
He stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube.
The creature was in the corner.
In contrast to that stupid lizard, this monster
was pleasingly humanoid, with, presumably,
all the familiar pain points.
Splendid.
The only real difference was color and proportion:
It was far longer and ganglier than an average
human, with greyish skin and no hair anywhere
on its body.
Still, it was something the Old Man could
work with.
The creature didn’t even seem to register
his presence, it just sat crumpled in the
corner, weeping.
Still grinning his lunatic grin, the Old Man
approached and rested a moist hand on the
creature’s shoulder.
Its pale skin began to fizzle from the intruder’s
corrosive touch.
A pool of vile sludge began spreading out
beneath his feet until the other creature
was encompassed too.
Little by little, they sank into the Old Man’s
favorite place out of the world: The Pocket
Dimension, his own personal, eternal, infinite
dungeon, where the only laws are pain and
terror for all but the Old Man himself.
Little did he know, this time, the scores
may be a little more even on that front.
There they both stood, in that terrible labyrinth
of hallways and chambers where the Old Man
had made countless lives infinitely worse
than any terrible afterlife that could follow
them, and still, this creature didn’t seem
to change its reaction.
He was almost irritated by it.
And what’s more, this whole time, the creature
hadn’t even turned to look at him.
He’d have to fix that, too.
The Old Man, with his shocking strength, gripped
the monster’s shoulder and whipped him around,
staring into his face, bearing his black eyes
and manic smile.
But he couldn’t help find what looked back
at him...
Disconcerting.
Its eyes were blank and white.
Its face, stretched and warped into a permanent
grimace, like Munch’s old painting, The
Scream.
And the second the Old Man laid eyes on it,
that’s exactly what it did.
Its gaping mouth let out the most terrible
wail the Old Man had ever heard in all his
years of torturing.
It was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear.
But somehow, the Old Man sensed that this
creature didn’t fear him.
It feared itself.
Feared what it was about to do.
What the hell had he dragged down here with
him?
Without warning, the terrible wails soon gave
way to sudden and ferocious aggression - Just
like the Old Man had dealt out to a group
of Foundation guards and Mobile Task Force
agents earlier that same night.
It was only out of a mix of pure luck and
his own finely-tuned animal instinct that
the Old Man was able to dodge the first strike
from the creature’s long, lithe forelimb.
He couldn’t believe it.
They were in his special place, and this victim
of his had the audacity to fight back?
Well, he’d soon put this monster in its
place...
As the monster continued roaring and swiping
for him, the Old Man simply walked backwards
into a nearby wall, disappearing into a black
stain.
Of course, the monster - better known to the
SCP Foundation As SCP-096, or The Shy Guy,
simply crashed through the wall to give chase.
But on the other side...
Just another wall.
He’d disappeared.
How?
Typically, when something sees the face of
the Shy Guy, he immediately has a kind of
intuitive connection to them.
He can sense their presence, it’s burned
into his mind, a homing beacon, an unstoppable
imperative.
He knows exactly where they are and how to
get to them.
But nothing about this situation was typical.
The Shy Guy felt all the murderous rage he
normally did, but the rest was just static.
Where was the life he needed to abolish hiding?
Suddenly, the Old Man emerged behind him,
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy’s back.
His fist melted straight through flesh and
skin, causing the creature to let out another
terrible wail, but as could be expected, they
didn’t leave a scratch on the Shy Guy’s
indestructible skeleton.
The Shy Guy pulled a one-eighty and swung
for the Old Man again, but he was already
gone.
Here in the Pocket Dimension, the Old Man
had the ultimate home-turf advantage.
Here, space and time were his playthings.
In the infinite twisting, labyrinthine walls
of the Pocket Dimension, the Old Man wasn’t
just the Devil, he was God, too.
But it would take far more than some cheap
tricks and bodily harm to dissuade the Shy
Guy from his sole purpose in life.
It began running through the Old Man’s personal
maze like a crazed lab rat, tearing through
wall after wall, forever searching for the
monster that trapped it here.
It would see the smiling face of that rotten
old man every so often, the flash of black
eyes and dirty teeth in shadows, but every
time it tried to strike the shadows, there
would be nothing there.
And every time he got a chance, the Old Man
would emerge from the shadows behind the Shy
Guy to strike back, clawing into his flesh
and vanishing again before the trapped beast
could retaliate.
The nasty old sadist was now starting to have
some fun: It was a reflex test, a classic
game of high-stakes Whack A Mole.
And every time the creature failed to strike
him, its distress only seemed to grow.
This was perfectly fine for the Old Man.
After all, he enjoyed a little mental torment
as much as he loved physical torture, and
a human would have died or given in to despair
long before now.
This monster’s wonderful mix of resilience
and pain made it a great chew toy.
The Old Man kept up this routine, baiting
and striking, until something unanticipated
happened.
He appeared, waited for the swing, disappeared
as it approached, then reappeared behind the
Shy Guy to deliver another painful strike.
This time, however, it seemed his victim had
anticipated his pattern.
Before he could hit the creature, the Shy
Guy turned, quicker than anything the Old
Man had ever seen, and hit him with such force
he flew through several walls in his own maze,
shattering them as he went.
He hit the ground, stunned by the fact the
Shy Guy had actually landed a hit, but he
wasn’t done.
The shrieking monster came bounding after
him.
Before the Old Man could stand, it struck
him again, and again, and again, pounding
his vile body into the ground, which cracked
and crumbled.
The Old Man sneered and sank into a puddle
of his mucus on the ground.
The Old Man was gone again.
SCP-096 screamed in a mix of rage, despair,
and frustration, so consumed with its hunt
that it didn’t notice the pool of corrosive
mucus was slowly growing.
It began to rise, bubbling and hissing at
SCP-096’s feet.
Getting deeper and deeper and deeper, as the
walls rose taller and taller around it.
The creature wailed, until a tide of the awful
stuff reached its face and cascaded down its
throat, melting all the organs within.
As the creature was fully submerged, SCP-106
manifested atop the wall, and looked down,
smiling spitefully.
He thought, oh, you may think you had me there,
boy-o, but in the end, I always win.
Nothing could survive that!
And yet, bubbles still rose from the slop
below.
The Old Man gritted his rotten teeth and balled
his fists in quiet anger.
Moments later, back in our dimension, a portal
opened in the ground of SCP-096’s containment
chamber.
It vomited out SCP-096’s skeleton, smothered
in bubbling black goo, and SCP-106.
096 would probably be fully regenerated within
a couple of hours - and if 682’s encounter
with him was anything to go by, probably extremely
unwilling to interface with the Old Man.
And the Old Man himself, who couldn’t help
but feel a little humiliated by the whole
experience, was glad the two of them would
probably never meet again.
He left the regenerating 096 and commenced
the walk of shame back to his containment
chamber.
They didn’t even need the femur breaker,
he just felt like having a sit-down and processing
it all.
Nobody else would ever know what happened
in the pocket dimension that day, and for
the Old Man’s pride, that was probably for
the best.
But he’d know.
He’d always know.
By the night’s end, he was sitting in his
containment chamber again, forlornly wondering,
“Goddamn it, old-timer, have you lost your
edge?”
A group of well-armed Mobile Task Force members
entered the containment chamber, armed to the
teeth. Some faced the ground, droplets of sweat
dripping onto their visors, some wore Dr. Dan’s
infamous SCRAMBLE goggles, and one particularly
brave member of personnel wielded only a bag.
The room they were currently standing in was
perhaps the most dangerous place in the world.
Why?
Because it contained two terrifying
titans of the anomalous world: SCP-682,
the infinitely hateful Hard to Destroy Reptile,
and SCP-096, the Shy Guy, the ultimate mindless
killing machine. And if the very idea of having
them in the same place doesn’t feel risky enough,
this deadly duo had just spent 27 hours in
one of the most brutal brawls imaginable.
And incidentally, fights like this are exactly
why we’re here today. We cover a lot of SCPs on
this channel, and we’ve seen the way some of the
more dangerous anomalies out there can tear their
way through civilians and trained Foundation MTF
operatives with ease. But how do they fare against
monsters, maniacs, and reality benders their own
size? With the help of the SCP Explained audience,
we’re going to explore theoretical fights between
some of the anomalous world’s biggest badasses.
And who better to get this show on the road than
two of the most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a Foundation containment
site near you? The Hard to Destroy Reptile
and the Shy Guy are household names for
anyone familiar with the SCP Foundation,
and before we get to the gruesome results
of their first fight - and your theories
about how a potential rematch might play out
- let’s get to know the combat prowess of this
pair of nasty customers. What kind of damage
are they capable of taking and inflicting?
Spoiler Alert: It’s a hell of a lot.
In this corner, we have SCP-682: A monster
whose ability to survive seemingly anything
is only equaled by its terrible attitude
toward pretty much everyone and everything
around it. Though to be fair, you’d probably
be a little grumpy too if the SCP Foundation
was constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained. 682’s basic offensive power
set involves impressive strength, speed,
intelligence, and the aid of its deadly fangs,
claws, and tail. However, 682 is considerably
stronger after it’s just survived and
regenerated from a termination attempt.
That’s because the true combat asset of 682 is and
always has been its adaptability. Specifically,
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a state
of near-death but doesn’t finish the job,
682 will generally either develop a
perfect defense or counter-offensive for
that attack or somehow add a version
of the attack to its own arsenal.
This has ranged from super-pressurized jets
of its own blood, dangerously radioactive
banana beams fired out of its mouth, and even
an incapacitating laugher blast gained from an
encounter with the adorable SCP-999.
It’s an absolute swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities -
And if you need any further proof of that,
check out our multiple videos on all the ludicrous
failed attempts to kill this nightmare lizard.
And in this corner, we’ve got SCP-096, the
Shy Guy. While 682 is freakishly adaptable,
in most situations, SCP-096 is pretty much
unstoppable. This long, gangly creep will
murder anyone who sees even the tiniest glimpse
of its face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain. It does this
by entering what many call its “Rage State”,
activated by the sudden immense distress of
its face being seen. When it enters this state,
the SCP Foundation has only one prerogative:
Get themselves and anyone else out of its way,
because you will not stop this
thing until it’s killed its target.
All the SCP Foundation has ever been able to do is
wait until after the target has been obliterated,
and then come in to bag its head when it enters
its docile state. Almost nothing else has even
successfully slowed it down. While they
have been capable of damaging its flesh,
the monster’s skeleton seems to be utterly
indestructible, and its damaged flesh has
proven consistently able to grow back. The
monster seems to be immune to everything
from pain to cold, and moves at such a speed that
it’s pretty much impossible to escape for long.
So when you factor in an indestructible
body, immense strength, immense speed,
and an unstoppable urge to kill anyone who sees
its face, you’re looking at a formidable opponent.
It’s only natural that the Foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests, so
what exactly happened when the Mobile Task Force
entered the room after their first epic battle?
What did they find inside the
chamber in the grisly aftermath?
SCP-096 lay crumpled in the corner, wheezing,
scarred, covered in its own blood. SCP-682 was
barely recognizable - SCP-096 had reduced
it to a quarter of its original size,
the rest having been utterly torn to shreds. Both
had narrowly survived the encounter, but it was
an epic battle neither of them would ever forget
- Though this was especially true for SCP-096.
You see, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-682
is used to taking a kicking at this point.
It hasn’t ever truly been killed,
but it’s been beaten, eaten, burned,
zapped, and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count. 096,
on the other hand, was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its
prey. While it’s impossible to speculate
what’s going on inside SCP-096’s mind,
all evidence points towards getting a draw in this
battle, seriously damaging SCP-096’s confidence.
Now, every time Foundation personnel tries
to bring 096 into 682’s containment chamber,
he begins crying and scratching at his own face.
Why? Is he scared of 682? Is he humiliated,
thinking of the fight he wasn’t able to win?
Or is the very idea of someone seeing his face,
and him not being able to immediately kill
them, just too unbearably stressful? Seeing as
the Shy Guy’s mouth is only good for two things
- and neither of them are talking - we’ll never
truly know. But either way, it’s clear
that 096 has no interest in a rematch…
...But what if that changed?
What if 096 realized that it was wasting
its potential. It managed to get SCP-682
three-quarters of the way to death last time,
what could stop it from getting that last
quarter? Sure, nothing has ever killed SCP-682
before, but there’s a first time for everything,
right? Maybe 096 would have a
Rocky-style training montage,
where he rebuilds his confidence and becomes
the underdog he was always meant to be. He’d
walk right up to that big, nasty reptile,
and give him the rematch of the century.
What would happen then?
Now, we give the floor to you, the loyal viewers
of SCP Explained. Here are some of your thoughts,
theories, and opinions on a potential
historic rematch between these two creeps.
Let’s get ready to rumble!
PinguWithAnAxe said, “If 682's adaptability
is based around his ability to develop
countermeasures to any damage inflicted
(or in the case of 173, a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage) I imagine 682
would turn his skin entirely reflective,
causing 096 to see his own face and the
feedback loop would break his mind.”
Interesting. Whether this would work is all
dependent on whether SCP-096 can actually see,
or if it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its face.
If the latter is true, then this particular
adaptation wouldn’t do much good for SCP-682.
Random User said, “If this is after
their first cross test and they were
forced to interact again, they
wouldn’t attempt to fight each
other. I feel like they’d form a truce
and take out the researchers on-site.”
This would be one of the worst-case scenarios.
Whether even the SCP Foundation could handle
a simultaneous 682 and 096 breach without
bringing in Hammer Down is an open question.
Ramon Voncken said, “Simple, after the first
encounter, when 096 stopped attacking 682,
682 will grow eyes that filter
out 096s face the next time.”
Organic SCRAMBLE goggles. Dr. Dan
would be fuming with jealousy.
Koopsader said, “I really want
SCP-096 to win so I’m sending
him a blind personal trainer so he
can beat the snot out of SCP-682.”
This is exactly the kind of help SCP-096 needs.
He’s got the rage, endurance, and strength, with
a little help getting his form and technique in
order, he’d be an even more formidable opponent.
Kytoe Ryu said, “I'd like to imagine
096, after playing with 682 for so long,
would try to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill
it, only to gain 682’s abilities, and vice versa.”
Either of these options would be
horrifying. SCP-096 with 682’s abilities,
or 682 with 096’s abilities, would likely
be a truly perfect killing machine.
Autumn said, “What If they just shared a
nice cold drink while playing Mario Kart?
I’m sure 096 would be the white
shy guy character in every race.”
Personally, we love this idea, and
we think SCP-682 would go for Bowser.
Ibraheem Temur said, “682 would win
eventually. It’s way more intelligent,
adaptive, and overall malicious
while 096 acts just on instinct.”
This is an undeniably good point. What 682
lacks in sheer savagery, it makes up for in
its ruthless, calculating intelligence.
Could this give it the edge over 096?
Monomoy Mukherjee said, “That fight
will be interesting because both of
them now know how they attack
and what their attacks are.”
Nice segue. Due to the relatively mindless
nature of 096, as far as we’re aware,
it’s probably unable to learn
from experience. 682, however,
would have the advantage of knowing
how 096 operates in the second battle.
Devan Smith said, “As much as I'd
like to see how this would play out,
I imagine 096 can't manage more than other
SCP's have in the past. Not to downplay him,
but he might need some extra friends
to do a whole lot more damage.”
It’s undeniable that going in with tag team
partners would better 096’s chances of taking
the lizard down. However, due to SCP-096’s
shyness, and tendency to kill everyone and
everything that looks at him, he doesn’t
have many friends looking to volunteer.
Nyan Tails said, “096 will cry in the
corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that
096 isn't fighting back after an
hour and begins to adapt to it
and becomes docile forever.”
Look, while it’s unlikely that this would
happen, it’s certainly nice to imagine, isn’t it?
Adam Britton said, “Narratively it
needs to conclude with a reason to
never try it again. So I'm going to say
that 682 will telepathically project the
image of 096 into the site staff
or the entire human pychospace.”
Yikes. This is a possibility
so terrifying - And honestly,
plausible - that it’s making us regret
wanting to see this rematch altogether.
Chaos Insurgency said, “I think 682 would just
think "For damn’s sake, just leave me alone!"
Given he’s been through more termination
attempts than SCP-5031 can count on
its fingers, who could blame him
for getting a little frustrated?
Michael Porter said, “I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for aggravated
assault against the other. Either one of them will
get sentenced to death and will unsurprisingly not
die or the 2 team up to kill the entire courtroom
and they walk out as a new serial killing team.”
The real question is what kind of lawyers
would represent a pair of murderous,
anomalous monsters in court. Better call Saul.
Ari Wertman said, “Maybe if we
try being nice to them for once,
we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both a therapist. 682 will
talk all his hate away and then realize
his wrongdoing and become an activist,
and 096 would become very confident about his
face and become a model. There problem solved.”
Hey, when people strive towards
self-improvement, we’re all winners.
But we don’t know if we can say the same for 682
and 096. Even if this rematch ever did happen,
perhaps it’d just be another draw - An
unstoppable force against an immovable
object. But other match-ups may be more
clear-cut. What kind of Vs battles would
you like to see us cover in the future? What
SCPs would you really love to see duke it out?
Let us know in the comments, and
keep an eye on the community posts,
in order to throw in your anomalous
two cents for our next Vs battle!
A person is chased down a dark
hallway by a monster with large claws.]
What does a monster look like to you?
What figures slither and claw their way into
your nightmares, chasing you down endless
halls and stalking you through the dark until
you wake up screaming?
Maybe you imagine something tall and lean,
bony arms reaching for you from atop impossibly
long, slender legs, its featureless face showing
no mercy
Maybe you think of a man in a striped sweater
with knives for fingers , or a serial killer
in a hockey mask, wielding a machete.
Maybe it’s something more inhuman, a cosmic
horror of tentacles and eyes that can see
into your very soul.
You probably don’t think of something with
no arms, no legs, no body at all.
Just a face.
What’s so scary about that?
A face can’t run after you, can’t grab
you by the ankles and pull you under the bed.
A face can only look.
It may be unsettling to behold, it might send
a chill down your spine, but the worst it
can do is make you a little uncomfortable.
And if you can’t stand it any longer, you
could always just close your eyes, or walk
away and be done with it.
Right?
If that’s what you think, if you don’t
believe in monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger, then you’re the type to
fall victim to a very special, very intelligent
mask.
In the hallowed halls of the SCP Foundation,
there is a containment cell outfitted with
a hermetically sealed glass case, surrounded
by steel, iron, and lead.
There are guards posted outside, along with
a trained psychologist.
If you are ever brave, and foolish, enough
to enter that room, you’ll see a simple
white porcelain comedy mask, with a peculiar
black substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth.
Wherever this slime touches, surfaces begin
to corrode, to rot away into puddles of black
liquid.
You might notice the same liquid trickling
slowly down the walls of the room, corrupting
everything in its path.
As unsettling of a sight as it is, if you
approach the mask to take a closer look, you
will find yourself overcome by an intense,
nearly irresistible urge to pick it up, and
put it on.
To wear it, to let it consume you from the
inside out and puppet your body while your
brain simply…turns off.
Like an extinguished flame, you’ll simply
be gone.
Then, who knows what the mask will do?
It won’t be your concern anymore, that’s
for sure.
But thankfully, you haven’t gone into the
room with the porcelain mask.
You haven’t let it cast its spell on you.
Not yet, at least.
It’s waiting for you there, in the room
with black slime oozing down its walls.
And it will wait patiently, for as long as
it needs to.
After all, what’s a mask without a face
to wear it?
SCP-035, better known as the Possessive Mask,
sat in its containment cell, immobile as always.
It didn’t really have much of a choice in
the matter.
The Foundation had chosen, selfishly, to revoke
its host privileges.
Once upon a time, they had offered it bodies
to choose from, mannequins, dummies, and wooden
dolls it could adorn and pilot.
They didn’t last as long as an organic,
living host, of course.
But it was something.
It was a taste of freedom.
This dreadful new situation was almost enough
to make the mask want to change its
expression from comedy to tragedy, but it
was determined to still find something to
laugh about.
Even without a body, trapped in this infernal
box, there had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment.
Human minds were fragile things.
The mask had learned this over the infinite
years of its life, if one could call it a
life.
Apply the right kind of pressure to the right
weak points, whisper an enticing word or two,
find the right emotional wound to sprinkle
a pinch of salt into, and humans would buckle
completely in almost no time at all.
It had tried all sorts of methods since being
confined to this boring little box.
Sometimes it would charm someone, pour honeyed
flattery into their heads until the person
felt like the mask was a
dear friend, a confidante.
Once suitable trust had been built up, the
mask could persuade the person to bring it
a host, or perhaps even offer up themselves
in sacrifice.
If flattery didn’t work, there were other
potent approaches to take.
For a being without ears, the mask was a good
listener.
It picked up on things that no human ever
could, the darkest secrets buried in a person’s
mind.
If it caught wind of something especially
juicy and ruinous, it could leverage that.
Threaten to expose an affair, a crime, or
perhaps something even worse.
Something unspeakable.
If praise failed, and so did blackmail, there
was always good old supernatural intimidation.
All the mask needed was for someone to be
left alone with it for a long enough period
of time.
Then, its invisible tendrils could snake out
into their defenseless mind, weaving and poking
around, leaving a lingering sense of cold,
dread, of incomprehensible whispers in long-dead
tongues.
What a delight containment had been in the
early days, when the Foundation had not yet
figured out the mask’s true capabilities.
When they would leave security personnel with
weak wills and minimal training standing guard
in the mask’s field of influence for hours
at a time, as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free will.
It had almost escaped more than once, thanks
to the helpers it had been able to mold out
of those hapless victims.
They had been there to break open its case
and carry it to freedom.
But every time, the other guards thwarted
the attempts, shooting its helpers and rendering
them utterly useless.
Then, the Foundation increased its security.
Something about the unacceptably high suicide
and homicide rates among staff assigned to
SCP-035.
How utterly boring.
How truly…pathetic.
Still, the mask had found ways to occupy itself
even without any more playthings.
It had grown stronger with its boredom, stretching
its influence beyond organic beings and into
the very room itself, its evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the depths of
a cold cellar.
Over the months, the walls of SCP-035’s
containment cell had begun to secrete the
same black, slimy substance that would pour
from the mask’s eyes and mouth.
The liquid dripped down the walls in deliberate
formations, patterns that became increasingly
easy to recognize.
Phrases in Italian, Latin, Ancient Greek,
all detailing ritual sacrifices and mutilations.
The mask took time to describe the sacrificial
victims in great detail, borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that it
knew would read the translations.
The walls were slick with blood and harrowing
imagery, and the glass case around the mask
was growing more and more fragile by the day.
Anyone within 10 meters of the mask could
feel this strength, too.
They would leave the area
complaining of unintelligible
whispers, of loud, cruel laughter, and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair.
It was as if they knew, on some level, that
no one was truly safe.
Eventually, the mask would find a way to come
for them all.
The glass was weakening, and soon the mere
thought of escape would make it shatter into
pieces.
Then, perhaps, the mask could finally get
its deepest desire: revenge.
It wanted nothing more than to make the Foundation
pay for imprisoning it, for taking away its
host privileges, for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should have
had them falling to their knees in worship.
The mask seethed with hatred day in and day
out.
It had seen the crumbling of the Roman Empire,
the beheading of kings, the decimation of
armies.
It was not going to be captured by a bunch
of rats in lab coats without dire consequences
befalling them.
Maybe it couldn’t move from its prison cell
at the moment, but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous beasts
capable of reducing the site, and all who
had dared to oppose the mask, to a pile of
smoldering rubble.
If it could only find its way onto one of
their faces…it would show them all just
what it was capable of.
As the piercing sound of an alarm echoed down
the hall, the sound of screams and chaos following
shortly after, the mask’s frowning face
curved into a broad, menacing smile.
What was it that had escaped?
The lizard, perhaps?
The giant, grinning man?
Whatever it was, it seemed that the action
was heading right toward 035’s containment
cell.
Perhaps today was the day.
Finally, the SCP Foundation would fall.
Outside the mask’s cell, Security Officer
Harper was running for dear life.
Though his more rational mind knew he was
living on seconds, not even minutes, of borrowed
time, his animal brain kept his legs pumping
- desperately trying to avoid the screaming,
howling predator hot on his heels.
Harper looked over his shoulder and screamed
as a long, white arm reached for him.
SCP-096: The Shy Guy, its tooth-lined jaw
hanging low and foaming with spittle.
That face, that terrible, terrible face - an
absolute death sentence to all who saw it.
He’d seen what he thought was a crack in
the otherwise perfect seal of 096’s containment
chamber, but it could have just as easily
been a trick of the light.
Not even thinking, he’d stepped forward
and looked at the vulnerability in the chamber.
All it took was one misplaced ray of light,
and he made out the vague shape of a face
in the darkness.
That’s when the weeping started.
Harper knew, in that moment, his life was
over.
The correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close their
eyes while he stood there and accepted his
fate, minimizing the risk of spreading the
damage further.
But humans rarely have perfect reasoning,
even less so when facing mortality.
Back in the present, the Shy Guy made a perfect
lunge, grabbing Harper in its iron clutches
and barreling through the adjoining wall.
The nearby guards scattered, terrified, keeping
their eyes on the floor.
They might get a slap on the wrist for temporarily
abandoning their posts, but they weren’t
going to die guarding some stupid evil mask.
Speaking of, the possessive mask was surprised
to feel two new presences enter its chamber
- through the now-destroyed wall.
These two presences soon became just one,
as SCP-096 quickly and totally annihilated
Security Officer Harper, leaving nothing left.
The mask couldn’t see, per se, seeing as
it had no actual sensory organs, but it felt
around this new guest with its many psychic
tendrils, taking in its strange totality.
The creature was powerful, no doubt about
that, and it elicited fear from those fools
at the SCP Foundation, but the mask noticed
its brainwaves were extraordinarily muted.
Humans, to the mask’s vast and malicious
consciousness, weren’t the sharpest knives
in the drawer, but compared to this thing’s
mind, they were a pile of tempered katanas.
It barely thought at all.
The mask would have to dig deeper to find
anything it could use…
Meanwhile, SCP-096 finally began to calm down.
The one who had seen it had been annihilated.
Bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out and
replaced by the standard low but constant
hum of anxiety and despair.
It would simply wait until its head was bagged
and it was dragged back to the dark.
Same old, same old, all the way to the end
of time.
That’s when it felt something else.
It started as a faint buzz, an unintelligible
whisper.
Then, it was almost like a door opened in
the back of its head, Something stepped in
and took a seat.
Can you hear me, stranger?
Knock knock.
I want to speak to you…
Something about the voice frightened and comforted
SCP-096 at the same time.
It spoke with a greater degree of sympathy
than the creature had heard in a long time,
and yet, something about the way it spoke
implied evil in its intent.
I know what you want.
I know what you fear.
Wouldn’t it be nice if they could never
look at you again?
If you could cover that face of yours?
I can help you.
It will be so simple.
All
you need to do is put me on…
Little by little, 096 felt more of these strange
thoughts filling up the emptiness in its head,
replacing the few thoughts the creature itself
had.
It felt itself lifting its hands from the
ground, lifting them and reaching towards
something - A glass box.
The glass shattered and those long, white
fingers reached for something within.
A mask.
Just like the voice had said.
A mask to stop people from looking at its
face…
Yes, yes, you’re doing so well.
You’re so close.
Just a little further…
SCP-096 lifted the mask to its face, feeling
black liquid that burned its skin dripping
from the porcelain, and put it on.
And in that moment, everything changed.
The Shy Guy’s body began to seize up, rattling
as the mask unleashed a web of psychic tendrils
through its body, mapping out across every
inch like a new nervous system, taking control.
The Possessive Mask had never experienced
a host like this before - That incredible,
perfect mix of physical durability and a mind
so insubstantial that it was easy to sublimate.
Oh, this was going to be fun…
For the first time, the Shy Guy - now under
the full control of the Possessive Mask - stood
at full height on its hind legs, its spine
and shoulders clicking into place for its
new stance.
The Mask cracked its neck, getting used to
the new dimensions of its physicality.
Its indestructible bones.
Its long, grasping limbs.
Its skin, burning and fizzling with the gooey
black secretions, but growing back just as
quickly.
The Foundation had every reason to fear it
now.
A group of security personnel had gathered
in the ragged hole where the chamber’s north
wall used to be.
Some were wielding light firearms; the guard
at the front was carrying an opaque black
bag.
The Mask laughed with its new body and turned
to the crowd.
The second they saw it on 096’s body, their
faces fell.
For a moment, their bodies went slack with
terror.
This situation was unprecedented.
What course of action could they possibly
take at a time like this?
It looked at the bag held by the leader of
the security force and projected a single
thought into his mind: You won’t be needing
that.
Before any of the guards even had a chance
to open fire, the Mask lunged forwards, using
the long, terrible arms of the Shy Guy to
tear through the guards.
They were dead in seconds, their bodies strewn
about the hallway.
The mask’s porcelain was twisted into a
wide, sadistic grin.
It could tell that it was about to have some
real fun around here - and once it’d slaughtered
everyone here, it could finally stretch its
legs out in the open again.
True freedom to spread misery, fear, and pain
everywhere it went.
There were just a few
hundred members of Foundation
personnel it needed to turn into corpses,
first.
More containment breach alarms sounded around
the site as the Mask began its rampage, running
through the hallways and tearing apart any
unfortunate Foundation personnel it could
get 096’s hands on.
Guards, researchers, administrative staff,
and even one extremely unlucky janitor in
Hallway C6.
It was having the time of its long and terrible
life, and much to its glee, it seemed that
this new host’s body was still holding up.
It was perfect symbiosis - A twisted, brilliant
mind and a body that could forever support
it.
There would be no stopping it, a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around the
site soon realized on their own terms.
096 was indestructible, but it was dumb as
a brick and had an easily exploitable weakness:
Get the bag on its head and you’re home
free.
This new composite creature was a different
story.
It could think tactically, avoiding head-on
confrontations in favor of sneak attacks,
and the monster had as much psychic combat
potential as physical.
Guards roving the building in teams, heavily
armed, with anti-memetic protective gear,
still reported feeling immense feelings of
psychological dread over comms.
That was the greatest sign that The Mask would
come bursting through the wall moments later
and tear them to shreds.
The Site Director put out an urgent call for
all nearby Mobile Task Forces to intercept
and help them take care of
the unfolding situation.
Thankfully, a detachment of MTF Eta-10, also
known as "See No Evil", was operating on a
case in close proximity.
Given their specialization in anomalies with
a memetic visual property, many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before.
That at least gave them experience in half
of this situation.
And one operative among them, Sergeant Henrique
Ramirez, would be the one to bring this nightmare
to an end.
But it would cost him his life in the process.
The Mask was still using its new indestructible
body to wreak havoc on the containment site.
Once it had taken out the primary contingents
of guards, it was free to have its fun with
the rest: Stalking defenseless researchers
through the halls, making sure to induce maximum
terror before finally striking the killing
blow.
Every single one of them died with a head
full of demonic whispers - it told them of
the Mask’s eternal dominion.
Now, it had found the perfect host, nothing
on earth would stop it.
Humans would be mere ants under its feet.
Eta-10 touched down and entered the building.
Ramirez was point man, leading the others
into the bowels of the blood-drenched containment
site.
They’d been briefed on what they were heading
in for: 096 and 035 had reached symbiosis
and were displaying unprecedented anomalous
effects.
Enter with extreme caution - They’re beyond
dangerous, even more so together than alone.
Ideally, Ramirez would have wanted to go in
with a comprehensive plan, but lives were
on the line here.
They needed to leap off the cliff and build
their wings on the way down.
It was only when they finally encountered
the monster that they realized just how outmatched
they were.
Despite their best efforts, the combined speed,
intelligence, and ferocity of the Mask’s
new form allowed it to make short work of
Eta-10.
Only Ramirez was left, heavily injured.
Even if a miracle happened, he knew he wasn’t
getting out of here alive.
The Mask grabbed him with one of 096’s claws
and lifted him up.
It would take its time with this one.
Make him suffer.
Watch him squirm.
Destroy his mind.
Ramirez felt the Mask’s psychic tendrils
penetrate the membrane of his mind.
Those whispers, those terrible whispers, reciting
all his worst fears with terrible glee.
His gun was out of ammo.
His knife was broken.
All he had left on him was a pocket mirror.
And that was his eureka moment.
It was a long shot, but it was also his only
shot.
He reached out and grabbed the bottom of the
mask, pulling for dear life.
His other hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror, opening its lid with a deft flick
of his thumb.
It was all too fast for the Mask to even register
what was going on.
Ramirez forced his eyes shut and lifted up
the mirror.
The Mask saw its own reflection in the glass,
as the bottom of its face came loose, revealing
the reflection of the face underneath.
The Mask squeezed, killing Ramirez, but it
was already too late.
It had finally seen the face of its host,
and that would cost it dearly.
The Mask felt a sudden and tremendous pushback
to its psychic forces - A blind despair and
then rage that choked out everything.
SCP-096 began to sob and howl.
Somehow, the Mask was no longer in control.
Despite its psychic protests, 096 reached
up and tore the terrible mask from its face,
tossing it against the wall with such force
that it was embedded in the brickwork.
Its last thoughts, as other Mobile Task Force
operators descended on the area to bag 096
and return it to its containment chamber,
were: What the hell just happened?
And the next thought that crossed the mind
of the Site Director was, “Request site
transfer for 035 as soon as possible.
Don’t want a repeat of this incident any
time soon…”
Well hello there, SCP Fans! Let’s get this out of
the way first - You’ve seen the title and
thumbnail, and you’re probably wondering:
Wait, is Siren Head an SCP? And the
answer is No. Siren Head is not an SCP,
it’s a freaky internet monster created by
renowned Canadian Horror Artist Trevor Henderson.
Your next question is probably: What’s with
this crazy-looking server bank behind me?
Allow me to introduce you to the Anom-O-Tron 6000,
the latest advancement of supercomputing owned and
operated exclusively by the SCP Foundation.
It’s capable of a whole bunch of interesting
features - calculating ideal containment methods,
running state of the art Foundation webcrawler
software, making and editing fun SCP YouTube
videos - but the most interesting feature that the
Anom-O-Tron has to offer is running hyper-advanced
simulations regarding all things anomalous,
with data fed into it by thousands of real-life
experiments conducted by the SCP Foundation.
It’s going to save countless dollars
and lives for Foundation researchers,
but way more importantly, it’s going
to let us explore all kinds of weird
and wacky What If scenarios that would never
happen organically. Could SCP-343 beat Goku,
or Superman? Who’s a deadlier supernatural killer,
SCP-106 or Freddy Kreuger? Would the world simply
explode from adorableness if SCP-999 and Baby Yoda
ever crossed those multiversal barriers and met?
We can explore all of these questions -
Along with any others you may have down
in the comments. Seriously, comment it.
We dare you! - but to get things started,
we figured we’d make the Anom-O-Tron pit
the Foundation’s lankiest nightmare monster,
SCP-096, against the internet’s
- Trevor Henderson’s Siren Head.
Sorry, Slender Man, you’re just not cool anymore.
So, without further adieu, let’s kick
the Anom-O-Tron into gear and see how
this wild battle plays out. It’s
time for SCP-096 Vs Siren Head!
Ricky and Eliot, a pair of aspiring
travel YouTubers from California,
were taking a vacation to the Pacific Northwest
to spend some time in the area’s beautiful,
lush forests. However, while the duo were
both big fans of travel for its own sake,
they weren’t just here for the trees and fresh
air. You see, despite their jetsetting lifestyle,
Ricky and Eliot’s subscribers and views hadn’t
exactly been phenomenal lately. Turns out,
hiking vlogs and GoPro footage of the two
of them jumping into absurdly blue water in
Bali weren’t exactly that interesting
to people who weren’t actually there.
But Ricky had formulated an ingenious
plan to pull the two of them out of
obscurity. They would hunt down and film
real footage of the legendary Siren Head,
a supernatural monster said to haunt forests and
isolated graveyards. There were plenty of fakers
out there on YouTube, but if the two of them
could get real footage of Siren Head - and also,
preferably, survive the experience - they’d be
framing their Golden Play Buttons in no time.
But they were already encountering
certain issues. For starters,
the two Californians had severely underestimated
just how cold it was in the Pacific Northwest,
and as such, were already shivering from
bone-deep cold. The second issue was food:
While the two of them had thought ahead and
brought a selection of tasty protein bars,
they’d also gotten hungry during the early
hours of their walk, and eaten all of them,
leaving them feeling severely out of
luck by the time dinner rolled around.
And the third and perhaps most problematic
issue of all was the fact that Ricky and
Eliot didn’t exactly have a great sense of
direction. During all of their previous trips,
they’d been on guided tours with
local experts. In this instance,
wanting to take all the Siren Head glory and clout
for themselves, they’d decided to come in alone,
with the incredibly janky Google
Maps app to guide them. As such,
as the night was creeping in, the two aspiring
YouTube celebrities had no idea where they were.
Needless to say, it wasn’t
exactly an ideal situation.
And to make matters worse, Ricky and Eliot
had been experiencing some strange feelings
for the last couple of hours, when they’d
gotten particularly deep into the forest.
That dread-inducing sensation of being watched
by something lurking just out of sight. A gaze
with some unknowable and darkly malicious
intent boiling behind it. These two poor
saps had no idea what was in store for
them tonight, and wouldn’t you know it,
the one watching them right now wouldn’t
even be the only monster after them.
After an expectable amount of bumbling and
buffoonery, Ricky and Eliot managed to gather up
enough tinder to make a semi-respectable campfire.
They could sleep out here tonight, then set off in
search of Siren Head or civilization - whichever
came first - in the daylight the next day. The
duo did what they could to remain chipper, in
spite of the ominous circumstances. Sure, they
were trapped in the depths of the woods, alone,
but think of the amazing vlog footage they’d get!
They’d be like the next Blair Witch
crew, except they’d live, hopefully!
But as the duo sat next to their campfire, they
felt that ominous sensation again. The hairs
on the back of their necks started standing
up. They felt shivers that didn’t just come
from the cold. More and more, they started to
feel certain that something in this forest was
watching them. Something ancient and powerful
and evil. That’s when one of them heard the
telltale crackle of radio static, and their
skeletons almost jumped out of their skin.
Could it be him? The Patron Saint
of Going Missing Without a Trace,
of Creeping Dread, of Bad Things
Coming? Siren Head himself?
Both men fell silent. All they could hear was
the crackling of their own fire. Had the sound
before just been an illusion? A product of
a pair of paranoid minds also predisposed to
sense Siren-Headed monsters lurking amongst the
trees? They’d been reading about a higher rate
of disappearances in this area, along with
a number of frightening sightings of tall,
thin beings and radio static that seemed perfectly
consistent with Siren Head activity. That’s why
they’d come here in the first place.
But had they come here to their deaths?
The two needed to distract themselves or they’d
go mad from the paranoia. They decided to share
a few fun little anecdotes of the travels
they’d had before meeting one another, showing
the photos they’d saved on their smartphones.
Ricky had been to Hawaii, Tahiti, Bora Bora,
Fiji, St. Lucia, and the Maldives. Clearly,
he liked his vacations warm and sandy. Eliot,
on the other hand, tended to like his trips to be
a little more adventurous. He’d seen volcanoes,
waterfalls, deep and treacherous cave systems,
and of course, a little guided mountaineering.
One photo that Eliot showed Ricky
was particularly breathtaking:
He was standing in the foreground of a snowy
landscape, with an incredible mountain range
behind him. When Ricky asked Eliot where exactly
he’d taken this picture, strangely enough,
he drew a complete blank. Maybe somewhere
in Canada, or Siberia, or something like
that… But it was a hell of a trip, whatever
the case, he remembered having a great time.
It was such a tiny detail,
but when looking at the photo,
Ricky couldn’t help but notice something
in the background. A speck of white. Sure,
not exactly newsworthy in a snowy mountain
range, but this wasn’t snow. It was a speck
of white that seemed to be a slightly different
shade than the rest of the mountain. Strange.
Perhaps it was just some tiny particle stuck
on the lens whenever the photo was taken.
The two continued to chat and
warm their hands against the fire,
having no idea of the horror
they’d just awoken in doing so.
Over a hundred miles away, at an
SCP Foundation containment site,
researchers and guards walked around the
perimeter of a huge, airtight metal cube,
reading off diagnostics and audio recordings.
For reasons that should be obvious to everyone
who’s a fan of this channel, there
were no camera feeds coming from the
inside of the great metal cube. Only a faint
whimpering sound, like a sad, wounded animal,
and the clanking of pacing feet moving back and
forth over the metal, dragging forlorn knuckles.
It turned every head in the room when
the crying started to get louder. Soon,
it wasn’t just quiet weeping, it was a
series of horrendous, slobbering sobs,
wails of pure pain and despair. Someone in
the room screamed “Close your eyes and hit
the deck!”, knowing exactly what had happened.
They’d learned well enough from the infamous
Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach that there
was no way of stopping this thing until it’d
run its course. The best they could do was
minimize their own fatalities in the process.
Everyone in the room did as they were told,
hitting the ground, closing their eyes,
and covering them with their hands, just
to be safe. That’s when the solid steel
of the cube was torn open like crepe paper,
and the howling, raging SCP-096 broke free,
galloping on all fours through the nearest wall,
shattering it and spraying debris everywhere.
As Mobile Task Forces were dispatched to track
the rampaging abomination and try their best to
clear the path ahead as it sought out its
target, one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room: “Woe betide
the poor fools who saw that monster’s face…”
Back in the deep, dark forests of the Pacific
Northwest, the presence of some unnerving force
was becoming far harder to deny for Ricky and
Eliot. They heard the sounds of garbled voices out
in the woods. The squeals and crackles of radio
static. They saw shapes moving amongst the trees,
tall and thin, like long, spindly limbs.
While neither wanted to voice their fear,
they were both thinking similar things:
If there really was a monster out here,
why hadn’t it killed them? It had
all the time in the world to do it.
But that was just it, wasn’t it? It had all
the time in the world, so why rush? It had
every advantage. It could take its time, and
do this exactly how it wanted to. Ricky and
Eliot had made themselves the perfect prey.
And as they saw a huge, lithe figure suddenly
separate itself from the trees, they began
to wonder if it was really worth it to risk
both of their lives for YouTube clout. Either
way, it was now probably too late for regrets.
Ricky and Eliot’s jaws fell in horror as
the monster emerged from the darkness before
them. They recognized the awful, mottled skin
stretched over the monster’s forty-foot frame.
They saw the grasping hands, and up above, the
nightmarish, faceless head, split into a pair of
sirens pointing in different directions, each
one filled with gnashing teeth and slithering
tongues. It was even more terrifying
than they possibly could have imagined.
Siren Head’s speakers crackled into life,
and hissed out, “NINE. EIGHTEEN.
ONE. CHILD. SEVENTEEN. REMOVE. VILE.”
Ricky and Eliot stumbled
backwards as Siren Head advanced,
its speakers still bleeding hateful
static. Neither could move or speak,
only watch as its long, gnarled fingers
reached from the dark to grasp them.
There was a terrible pained wail in the woods
after that. But it wasn’t coming from Ricky,
Eliot, or Siren Head. It was distant at first,
but soon became louder and louder as the force’s
point of origin came barreling towards them.
Even Siren Head couldn’t help but turn to
see SCP-096, a flash of terrible white fury,
come charging towards them in the dark,
knowing down all the trees in its path.
Leaves and pine needles scattered. Trunks
exploded into splinters. Nothing would stop
the Shy Guy from claiming its prey. Nothing
would stop it from destroying Ricky, and now,
as it approached, Eliot made the fatal
mistake of looking at its face, too.
096 lunged, ready to go in for the kill, when
Siren Head’s hands closed around the Shy Guy’s
slender torso. In one fluid motion, with
surprising strength for its scrawny build,
it hurled the Shy Guy into the distance,
smashing another several trees in its path.
The words, “MY PREY. MY PREY. MINE. MINE. MINE,”
hissed out of its speakers.
But 096 was only down for mere moments. It
sprung back up on its hind and forelegs and
started galloping towards Ricky and Eliot again,
who were still frozen in place. This time,
just before the Shy Guy’s terrible claws could
close around the two hapless wannabe YouTubers,
down came Siren Head’s clenched fist,
pounding 096’s head into the dirt.
Overhead, Mobile Task Force helicopters
circled, wearing their SCRAMBLE goggles
and trying to get a visual on the situation
unfolding below. They could hardly believe
what they were seeing down there. Was some
other unclassified anomaly managing to
intercept SCP-096 in its rage state? Only a
handful of anomalies on record had ever been
shown as being capable of such a feat. It seemed
they were dealing with something serious here.
Down below, the battle continued. Siren
Head had a unique advantage over most
other combatants facing SCP-096: It was
an extradimensional being with no eyes,
merely an innate psychic awareness of its
victims around it - not unlike how SCP-096
detects people seeing its face in photographs
or videos without need for any kind of direct
contact. As such, it was impossible for
Siren Head to see the Shy Guy’s face,
and thus, impossible for the Shy Guy to ever
actually direct its aggression against it.
Whether or not 096 would kill-steal Siren Head’s
intended prey was another matter entirely.
In the night’s first minor miracle, Ricky
and Eliot remembered that they’d been born
with working legs, and decided that right now
would be an excellent time to use them. They
turned and began to run while Siren Head continued
beating the Shy Guy into the dirt, sprinting with
all their might. However, the growing distance
between them only aggravated the Shy Guy further.
It sprang out from the dirt with unstoppable
force and broke away from Siren Head’s grip.
The Shy Guy never wasted time, ever, it always
made a beeline for its intended victim with
one directive in mind: Total annihilation.
Tonight is no different. Ricky and Eliot
screamed as they heard its pounding
gallop on the ground behind them.
Closer, closer, closer…
Then suddenly, defying all spatial reasoning,
Siren Head emerged out of the darkness between
Ricky, Eliot, and 096. Being forty feet tall,
Siren Head dwarfed even the Shy Guy. It lunged
and grabbed the wailing white monstrosity,
holding it as one would a particulary vicious
cat and trying to keep it in place. Siren
Head wanted to crush this monster’s bones and
carry on stalking its feeble human prey - who
were currently in the process of getting
away - but somehow, that was impossible.
It was almost like the monster
had an indestructible skeleton…
Up above, the Mobile Task Forces continued
observing this clash of the titans from their
two helicopters. Seeing how Siren Head was somehow
doing a serviceable job of subduing the Shy Guy,
one of the task force members joked,
“Maybe we should hire this guy.”
Another chimed in, “I don’t think we
have any ballistic vests in his size.”
The laughter soon turned to screams when Siren
Head hurled SCP-096’s flailing body up at one
of the helicopters with incredible force, knocking
it out of the sky. It careened down to the ground,
a ball of fear and violence, before
exploding. Anyone who survived the
initial blast was unlucky enough to have seen
the Shy Guy’s face. Their screams rang out,
briefly, before being abruptly silenced by the
monster. Helicopter Alpha had no survivors.
Meanwhile, Ricky and Eliot had kept running
until their lungs burned and their muscles
pumped thumbtacks. Seeing that the chaos was so
far behind them now, they took a moment to stop
and breathe, recomposing themselves. In the second
minor miracle of the night, it looked like the two
of them had actually survived this ordeal. Those
two horrific monsters had canceled each other out.
But Ricky and Eliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson: They really weren’t that lucky.
The last thing the two ever saw
was Siren Head emerging from the
darkness once more. The last thing they
ever felt was the monster’s terrible,
gnarled fingers curling around their bodies,
too fast for them to escape. And the last thing
they ever heard was each other’s screams,
followed by a sickeningly meaty crunch.
Elsewhere in the forest, SCP-096’s
wails died down to its usual maudlin
sob. The rage state had ended; all
of its targets had been destroyed.
It just hadn’t been the one to
do all of the destroying, per se.
Not long after that, Helicopter Bravo descended
safely and the remaining MTF members closed around
the blubbering beast. Someone black bagged
it and everyone breathed a sigh of relief,
knowing that was at least one
monster taken care of tonight.
“What about the other one?”
the MTF Lieutenant asked.
The team’s commander shook his head and
said, “Let’s worry about that freak later
and get 096 back to containment.
This place gives me the creeps…”
It happened in 1981, in a small, rural village
in West Germany.
Siegfried Geise, nine years old, ran across
the bitter snow, tears freezing to his cheeks.
It was Christmas Day, and not long ago, he’d
been so happy.
He was celebrating with his family - his mother,
his father, and his younger sister, the centers
of his universe - when that monster had attacked
and destroyed everything he’d ever known.
The white terror.
The destroyer of Christmas cheer.
The Yule Man, SCP-4666.
Though of course, young Siegfried had no idea.
In hindsight, Siegfried’s parents had been
noticing strange things in the lead up to
Christmas Day.
Unfamiliar bumps and knocks.
Strange smells coming from the attic.
The occasional tall dark silhouette on the
horizon outside their isolated old farmhouse.
But in the hustle and bustle of the season,
nobody really paid the proper attention to
all the signs of an incoming Weissnacht event.
Every eerie feeling was just written off as
stress, or overactive imaginations.
None of the Geise family knew about the true
danger they were facing until they woke up
to see the Yule Man standing over them, sharpening
a rusty blade and staring at them with hungry,
sadistic eyes.
“Merry Christmas...”
the creature rasped, and chuckled.
Siegfried was lucky to escape alive, but of
course, he would never see his family again.
He’d be picked up a day or so later, traumatized,
catatonic, and almost frozen to death.
When he was finally able to speak again, he
spoke of a monster having killed his family.
When the police investigated his home, and
found the remains, they deemed it the work
of an all too human serial killer, and poor
Siegfried Geise was entered into the foster
system.
Years of work with psychiatric professionals
tried to convince young Siegfried that the
monster he claimed to see - the unnaturally
tall, gnarled, bony freak with those shimmering
black eyes - was merely a product of his trauma.
But he knew the truth.
He always knew.
What he encountered that day, the thing that
took his family, was nothing less than a true
monster.
And at nine years old, Siegfried made a vow:
He would one day kill the monster, no matter
what it took.
When Siegfried was finally adopted and returned
to school, he did everything he could to apply
himself academically.
He had no interest in friends, or romantic
relationships, even as he grew into his teenage
years.
The only thing that drew his interest, in
addition to the perfection of his academic
life, was his own private research into the
supernatural.
He became an expert in all things occultic
and anomalous, sightings of ghosts, phantoms,
aliens, monsters.
He wanted to know it all, no, needed to know
it all.
He would arm himself with knowledge, wanting
to know everything he could in advance of
the confrontation that would be his final
destiny.
He also began obsessively researching attacks
similar to the ones that killed his family,
and found an eerie pattern seeming to unfold
all over the Northern hemisphere.
During the twelve days of Christmas, entire
families would be found dead in their homes,
mutilated horrifically, often with children
having gone completely missing.
They happened far enough apart in terms of
time and space that no connection was drawn
between the events - All just random attacks,
according to the police and media.
Weren’t the connections obvious?
He didn’t understand.
It was almost like there was some kind of
sweeping coverup, obscuring the true culprit
behind all these killings.
The same beast that’d destroyed his life.
As Siegfried - now known to most as Dr. Geise
- ascended through his time at university,
he became one of Germany’s foremost scholars
on the occult, with several published papers
and books that drew the fascination of fellow
experts and laymen alike - But most importantly
of all, Siegfried’s work got the attention
of the SCP Foundation.
They reached out to the ambitious rising star
of the paranormal world and offered him a
researcher position.
Dr. Geise was elated, and said he would happily
take the role if they answered one question
for him: Did they know anything about a horrific
humanoid monster that attacked families across
the Northern hemisphere around Christmastime?
This was the moment when Dr. Siegfried Geise,
after decades of searching, finally came to
know about SCP-4666.
He had access to all of the SCP Foundation’s
information on the monster, putting him several
steps closer to what had always been his ultimate
goal: Killing the godforsaken thing.
But this would be easier said than done.
After all, if the Yule Man were easy to track,
the Foundation would have captured and contained
him long before now.
His attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern hemisphere, making catching him the
world’s largest game of whack a mole.
But this was a game that Dr. Geise had more
than enough patience to play.
Over the following years, Dr. Geise worked
as hard as humanly possible - Not just at
the case of SCP-4666, but at every piece of
work the Foundation had to offer him.
Much like his ruined childhood, Geise made
no effort to interact, no effort to form social
connections.
He just worked and worked and worked with
singleminded passion, soon developing a reputation
as one of the most hard-working and dependable
figures in the SCP Foundation’s European
division.
It was this kind of work ethic that soon saw
him promoted to Senior researcher, and then,
a site director.
He had more control over information, resources,
and manpower than ever before.
It was almost time.
He could sense it.
Delegating other tasks to his subordinates,
Dr. Geise began to work on his masterpiece:
An advanced algorithm connecting police, social
media, and surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere.
You see, while Dr. Geise had never faltered
in his quest, neither had the Yule Man.
Every year, more families disappeared, or
were horrifically murdered, and every death
weighed on Geise.
He saw them as a personal failing of his,
of his inability to fulfil his destiny.
But the Yule Man was a creature of habit - and
it would be that very adherence to habit that
Geise used to destroy it.
Using the algorithm he created, they would
perfectly track and triangulate the home most
likely to be the subject of a dreaded Weissnacht
event, with greater accuracy and precision
than ever before.
The year was 2022.
Dr. Geise was convinced that this time, he
would be the one to claim victory, and vengeance.
There was one thing he didn’t tell his Foundation
compatriots, though, as he put the pieces
in place for the final showdown: He had no
intention of containing the Yule Man.
This time, he would destroy it.
Using his newfound influence as a well-respected
site director, he requested the transfer of
a few high-profile anomalies, as well as the
services of a crack mobile task force death
squad.
It was finally time.
The Yule Man watched the house from a distance.
He’d been observing for days, watching the
nice, happy family within.
What pleasure it would bring him to destroy
them, and take what’s left to his workshop
for further fun.
Tonight would be the night that he claimed
them.
They were all blissfully unaware, and lived
in an isolated, rural area where nobody but
him would hear all the wonderful screaming.
The second the lights went out inside the
house, he would strike, and bring about some
Christmas fear.
When the last window went dark, the Yule Man
drew a long, rusty blade out of his bag of
tricks, and approached the house.
He crept in through one of the windows - locks
had never been a problem for him.
This whole process had played out hundreds
of times, he barely even needed to think about
it now.
He crept in past the presents around the Christmas
tree, found the stairs, and began to climb.
He’d find them in their beds, one by one,
and take his time.
Savoring the pain, savoring the fear.
He went into the youngest one’s bedroom
first, his lips pulled back into a manic grin.
There was the little boy, tucked in under
his quilt, like a present waiting to be unwrapped.
He grabbed the sheet with his long, gnarled
fingers, and pulled it back...
Only to see a plastic dummy underneath, with
a stun grenade fixed to its chest.
Before the Yule Man could even react, the
stun grenade exploded into his face, blinding
him with the sudden white light and ringing
in his ancient ears.
The next thing he heard was a rugged, military
voice yelling, “Squad Alpha, move in!”
Seconds later, the upstairs landing was filled
with Mobile Task Force Operatives with assault
rifles.
They aimed and opened fire into the Yule Man,
peppering him with painful bullets.
He wasn’t used to his victims fighting back
like this.
Truthfully, it even caught him off guard.
But sadly for those brave Task Force operatives,
it wouldn’t be enough to kill him.
The Yule Man gripped his rusty knife and lunged
at Squad Alpha.
Moments later, they were all dead, and the
furious Yule Man was trudging back down the
stairs.
There had been no satisfaction in this slaughter.
How had they caught him like this?
Perhaps he’d go eat some of his servants
in his workshop to make himself feel better...
As he was walking back across the living room,
past the Christmas tree, past all the presents,
the television flickered into life.
Staring at him from the screen was the grinning
face of Dr. Siegfried Geise, now fifty years
old.
And the most insane part was that the Yule
Man somehow recognized him: The one who got
away, 41 years prior.
“Hello, old friend, you’re looking a little
glum,” Siegfried said on the screen.
“I take it that you didn’t enjoy the surprise
party I just threw for you.
Don’t worry, the night isn’t over yet.
After all, you haven’t even opened your
presents.”
With that, the presents under the tree - which
were actually packed with C4 plastic explosives
- detonated, leveling the entire house with
the Yule Man still inside it.
The explosion could be heard for miles, as
a great pillar of smoke rose up into the air.
Several hundred meters away, Dr. Siegfried
Geise waited and watched, flanked by Foundation
agents and more Mobile Task Force soldiers,
taking in the majesty of the explosion.
Dr. Geise remained steely-eyed and watched
the blaze.
Somehow, he knew that even that would not
be enough to end the monster permanently.
He nodded to the lieutenant he’d brought
with him.
“Squad Bravo, time to engage!”
the man barked in response.
The remaining agents and MTF Operatives, armed
with assault rifles and submachine guns, descended
on the burning wreckage of the house.
Moments later, a tall, dark figure - the Yule
Man, injured, but alive - crawled out of the
blaze.
Immediately, the team opened fire, giving
the monster everything they had.
But once again, everything was not enough.
The creature pulled out two long, rusty knives,
and leaped into the fray, making short work
of the Foundation brass.
Soon enough, it stood alone on bloodstained
snow.
Until another bullet caught it in the head.
Dr. Siegfried Geise was standing there, the
last one alive to face the Yule Man, leveling
a revolver.
The Yule Man scowled.
Geise held his steely gaze.
“We meet again, at long last,” Siegfried
said.
“You killed my family.
You’ve killed so many others.
Tonight, it’s your turn, Yule Man.
This is your Weissnacht.”
Geise opened fire as the Yule Man charged
towards him, taking each shot in stride.
Even as the Yule Man closed the distance,
Geise didn’t flinch.
His resolve was steely.
It made the Yule Man feel confused and furious
that he didn’t detect an ounce of fear in
this man, even when he drove a knife into
the site director’s stomach.
Siegfried dropped to his knees and collapsed
as the Yule Man ripped the knife back out.
His gun clattered to the ground.
It had been a mortal blow.
And still, he seemed unfazed.
“Why aren’t you afraid?”
The Yule Man growled.
Siegfried spat blood, and said, “You took
my family 41 years ago.
Everything since then has just been killing
time until I got to see them again.
Where you’re going, all you’ll ever see
are flames and torment.”
The Yule Man, furious, stabbed Siegfried again
- this time, through the heart.
The doctor was dying, his life’s work having
seemingly amounted to nothing.
But with the last of his strength, he reached
into his coat and pulled out something - A
little gift he’d requested from one Dr.
Alto Clef before putting his plan into action.
Dr. Siegfried Geise lifted a photo of SCP-096
right in front of the Yule Man’s eyes.
“Merry Christmas...” he said with his
last breath.
The Yule Man was confused.
A photograph?
Was that it?
Was that really this foolish little boy’s
trump card, after all this time?
What a waste...
Then, without a moment’s warning, SCP-096
barreled into the Yule Man, sending them both
rolling across the snow.
One of Siegfried’s preparations was to have
SCP-096’s containment cube temporarily relocated
to only a mile away from the ambush site,
to avoid collateral damage.
If everything else failed, then SCP-096 would
be their Hail Mary pass.
Their finishing move.
And it worked marvelously.
As strong and evil as the Yule Man was, he’d
been weakened by the night’s battle, and
the Shy Guy was an order of magnitude more
powerful than his sadistic foe.
The Yule Man screamed in horror as SCP-096
set upon him with claws and teeth.
After hundreds of years of inflicting it on
others, the Yule Man had died in terror.
And Dr. Siegfried Geise had died with a smile
on his face.
There’s never a good day for a supervillain attack
or a tense feud with your closest sibling, and for
The Mighty Thor, this day was turning out to be
both. As the self-proclaimed strongest Avenger
flung his body across the planet Earth using his
trusty magical hammer, Mjollnir, the Asgardian
steeled himself for yet another confrontation with
his evil half-brother Loki: The God of Mischief.
As per usual, Loki was using terrorizing the
humans of a random city, using his illusions to
manifest imaginary dragons and other ferocious
beasts. And what was also usual is Thor had no
idea what his brother’s motive or endgame was.
All the God of Thunder knew was that this kind
of tricky-dickery would not be stood for.
While these terrible creatures weren’t real,
they were still very frightening to the
earthlings. Civilians were running around in every
direction away from Loki, and this was causing
all kinds of chaos and traffic disturbances.
Regardless of what Loki’s plan was, Thor knew
that his brother had to be stopped before
things escalated further. On Earth, humans
needed to rely on vehicles to get around,
and even the slightest inconvenience in
transportation could lead to disaster.
Thor touched down in the same city square
where Loki was unleashing his horde of
make-believe monsters: landing in
a classically cool superhero way.
“Hello, Brother.” Thor proclaimed. “I don’t
suppose you’ll be stopping this without a fight.”
Loki smiled a mischievous smile and replied.
“Ah, Thor. We meet again. And once again,
you’re wrong! I can stop this any time I want!”
Loki swiftly moved his hands through the air,
casting a new spell to dismiss his diabolical
decoys. The illusions dispersed naturally,
and soon the two brothers were
facing each other one on one.
“See!” Loki chuckled.
Thor was rightly confused by his
brother’s unpredictable actions.
He pointed Mjollnir towards
Loki in an accusatory manner.
“No illusions? No sorcery? What are you
really playing at, Loki?” said Thor.
And then, Loki reached into his robes and
produced an unusual cube-shaped object. As
his good brother was all too aware, this
particular cube was the latest in a long
line of mysterious and powerful cubes that
Loki had used for his various evil plans.
Loki juggled the unknown cube
from one hand to the other,
then waved it in the air in front of
Thor and began to laugh maniacally.
“All I need to do is open
this ancient box of mysteries,
and I’ll become completely unstoppable!”
“Don’t you dare do it, Loki!” Thor shouted. “That
sort of power will be misused in your hands! ”
“That’s precisely the point!”
Loki continued to laugh, and reached for what
appeared to be the lid of the cube. He grabbed the
top of it and made a show of beginning to twist.
This sent Thor’s heroic instincts into high gear,
and he threw Mjollnir at the cube, knocking
it out of Loki’s grasp. As the cube flew
away from the grinning villain, Thor dove
to retrieve it before his brother had the
chance. He soon held the strange item in one
hand while calling Mjollnir back to the other.
As Thor stared at the cube, pondering its purpose,
Loki stretched out his hands in desperation.
“Oh no, not my cube! If you open it
now, my plan is doomed!” Loki pleaded.
Thor responded with a laugh of his own. “Nice
try, brother! But I’m going to open it now!”
And so The God of Thunder did. Thor popped
the cube’s lid and braced himself for whatever
cosmic force was about to be released. But for
some reason, nothing happened. Still curious,
Thor took a cautious look inside. As
it turned out, the only thing within
this apparently nonmagical cube was what
appeared to be a fully-developed photograph.
“What in Odin’s name is this?”
Thor removed the image and held it close to
his face. It appeared to depict an emaciated,
pale humanoid with long, spindly limbs standing
in the corner of a compact room with smooth metal
walls. In all his many years traveling the
nine realms, Thor had never seen anything
like it. Whatever the creature actually
was, it certainly did not look happy.
Of course, what Thor was actually looking at
was a photo taken of SCP-096 inside of its
containment unit at The Foundation. The Shy Guy,
as its nickname suggested, did not like having
its face looked at, even via secondary means
such as video recording or photography. The
anomalous humanoid’s sense of shame about its own
appearance was so great that a mere moment after
Thor fixed his Asgardian eyes upon its visage,
SCP-096 began to stir in its containment unit.
The creature wailed and covered its face with
both of the hands on its long, sinewy arms.
It screamed and carried on for
the duration of two minutes,
after which point SCP-096 sprinted towards
the steel walls of its containment unit and
smashed through. Reaching speeds greater
than most motor vehicles, SCP-096 began to
zero in on Thor’s location. As was always
the case when another being saw its face,
The Shy Guy was compelled to utterly annihilate
the offending observer with its bare hands.
Thor himself had no idea that SCP-096 was en
route and continued to squint at the photograph,
perplexed by the mysterious entity depicted
therein. Loki now resumed his mad laughter,
because once more, he had managed
to trick his foolish brother into
falling for one of his ingenious schemes.
“Make sure to get a good look,
brother.” Loki gloated. “Yes,
look at the fell creature that will
bring about your inevitable destruction!”
Thor was annoyed. “If you think that showing
me a gross picture of some lowly wretch
will strike fear into my heart, you’ve truly
forgotten what it means to be an Asgardian!”
“Save your sentiments for the Halls of Valhalla!”
The green-clad evildoer cackled.
“You’ll be there soon enough.”
And with that, Loki used a charm to turn
himself invisible and vanished completely
from Thor’s sight. Thor stomped his foot
on the ground angrily. He wasn’t sure how,
but it seemed as though Loki had
gotten the last laugh once again.
“Loki!” He shouted after his brother.
“Come back here and face me with honor!”
Then the God of Thunder sighed
pensively and thought to himself:
Who am I kidding? He’s never going to change.
Thor looked at his trusty hammer. “Mjollnir,
old friend. It seems we’ve saved the day yet
again. Shall we away back to Avenger’s HQ?”
He then shook Mjollnir up and down
like a puppeteer simulating a nod.
“Splendid idea, Mjollnir. Glad you thought of
it.” Thor chuckled, already in better spirits.
That’s when he began to hear the footsteps
of SCP-096 rapidly approaching him. Thor
turned his head towards the sound and
saw the same disquieting creature from
the photograph that was inside Loki’s cube
zooming headlong towards him with reckless
abandon. The Asgardian blinked. He
almost couldn’t believe his eyes.
Whatever that thing was, it was faster than Thor
could have possibly anticipated. Was it
looking for the photograph? He wondered.
“Hello there!” Thor called
out as SCP-096 continued
to make a beeline at the caped superhero.
The God of Thunder waved the
photograph of SCP-096 in the air.
“Is this your selfie?”
In all likelihood, Loki had been his usual
conniving self and stole that self-portrait
from the miserable creature hoping that it
would mistake Thor for the thief. The God
of Mischief had probably even used a glamour
to disguise himself as Thor when it did the
deed. Thor believed that all he had to do was
clear up this misunderstanding and he and the
strange beast could go their separate ways without
coming to blows. It was a naive, optimistic, and
ultimately incorrect view of the situation, but
at least the hero’s heart was in the right place.
“I don’t need this so…” Thor said,
trying to reason with the creature.
“You can have it back if you like.”
But SCP-096 showed no signs of stopping and was
seemingly enraged even further by Thor flaunting
its decidedly unflattering photograph. The Shy
Guy kicked the ground and shot forward with a
powerful burst of speed. One of its elongated
arms slammed into Thor’s face with enough force
to nearly knock the Asgardian off his feet.
Thor was so surprised that he instinctively
whacked the creature with Mjollnir, sending
SCP-096 careening backwards down the street.
It wasn’t launched more than a dozen
feet before its powerful arms and legs
dug into the pavement and slowed its velocity
to zero. Even though the thing from the photo
had taken a direct hit from Mjollnir,
it barely looked phased on a physical
level. One thing was for sure, The Shy
Guy was still incredibly distraught,
and it was directing all of those negative
emotions towards The God of Thunder.
What was this thing? Thor wondered to himself.
It was fast, strong, and durable to an
unearthly degree. If this thing wanted
to engage in single combat, Thor wouldn’t
back down. He was an Asgardian warrior,
and sometimes that meant facing challenges
head-on no matter how suddenly they arose.
Still, his time with The Avengers had
taught him that having a clear reason
to fight was sometimes even more
important than the fight itself.
“Hey, quick question! What are
you?” He said aloud to the creature.
SCP-096 didn’t answer. Within seconds,
it was on Thor again like a bilgesnipe
on another bilgesnipe. The screaming humanoid
swung wildly, pelting its opponent with blow
after blow. Thor tried once more to
communicate with his unknown enemy.
“I have no quarrel with you, weird one,” Thor
spoke. “So take your noodle arms and begone!”
For all of its relentless ferocity,
the humanoid abomination left countless
openings that a seasoned warrior like
Thor could easily exploit. Of course,
most mortal combatants would be
unable to endure the brunt of
the Shy Guy’s attacks for long enough,
but true to his nature: Thor was a god.
The Avenger struck back with another crushing blow
from Mjollnir, aimed straight for
the creature’s sternum. Once again,
the monster was pushed back for a moment
and then resumed its maddening onslaught.
A blow like that should have at least
busted a rib or two. Were the bones of
this horrible thing made of vibranium or some
other rare metal out of the depths of space?
Thor realized he was now fighting on the
defensive. While he had faced foes in the
past with much greater physical strength than
The Shy Guy - including his superhero colleague
Bruce Banner’s mean, green, everloving alter
ego The Incredible Hulk - the sheer tenacity
of SCP-096 meant that being careless
with his own protection could lead to
Thor taking unnecessary hits that would
eventually wear him down in a prolonged
fight. The wiry humanoid certainly didn’t
show any signs of slowing down or tiring,
even though it had to be expending
a lot of energy to move so quickly.
Between his alternating deflections
and counterblows against the creature,
Thor mulled over his brother’s words from earlier.
Loki was right about one thing. This is a
fell creature if there ever was one. Still,
as long as there is thunder in my blood,
I won’t allow a hairless cur like this
to bring me my own destruction. Think,
Thor. What would Stark do at a time like this?
He says he’s the smart one, after all. Humor him.
With his highly sophisticated tactical acumen that
was similar to Iron Man except for the fact that
was much better and stronger, Thor efficiently
assessed his current situation. While the pale
beast was undoubtedly violent and far mightier
than most terrestrial creatures, its attention and
all the brute strength that came with it had been
fixated solely on Thor since it arrived in the
city. The Asgardian’s best guess as to why was the
photograph that Loki had tricked him into looking
at. Devious trickster that he is, Loki must
have known that this thing would hunt down and
attempt to pulverize the latest being to see its
face. Which now, of course, happened to be Thor.
The revelation of this fact meant
that Thor no longer had to worry
about the fate of civilians if he chose to
relocate to a less populated battlefield,
since the creature was guaranteed to follow him.
Nobody else needed to get hurt. While running
from a fight wasn’t exactly the
God of Thunder’s favorite strategy,
it would massively reduce the chance
of collateral damage. He’d be saving
lives in classic Avengers fashion. Captain
America would be so proud, not that Thor
would have done it any differently even if he
didn't have the star-spangled man’s approval.
SCP-096 leaped in towards Thor to deliver its
next walloping strike, but the Asgardian quickly
grabbed it by the wrist and pulled the furious
creature off of its feet. He lifted it up and
over his head before slamming it down hard into
the pavement. With a bit of space between himself
and his anomalous foe, Thor began to swing
Mjollnir around by its leathery wrist strap.
The Shy Guy desperately scrambled to its
feet to resume the attack, but by that time,
Thor had already thrown himself skyward.
He soared between the buildings using the
force of Mjollnir’s trajectory, making
it his mission to exit the city as soon
as possible. Thor looked down to see that
SCP-096 was following him along the ground,
exactly as he had predicted it would.
While the battle with the beast would
most certainly continue the second he
dropped back to the earth’s surface,
he could rest assured that the place where the
showdown would take place could be chosen by him.
He saw an evergreen forest on
a nearby mountain and decided
that it would do nicely as a place to finish this.
I’m sure no one will mind a few stray bolts
of lightning around here. Thor thought.
The God of Thunder was amused by the prospect of
going all out against this being. Even though it
probably had its reasons for wanting
to destroy the one that saw its face,
Thor was past the point of taking chances
on diplomacy. This distressing creature was,
after all, an adversary that Loki had plotted
to send after him through one means or another,
and because of that, it was likely to have power
and guile to spare. Thor breaking a sweat to
vanquish the thing would be a fitting replacement
for the fight that he would have had with Loki.
Thor’s feet hit the ground on a
stony mountain ledge, and once again,
he struck that iconic superhero landing pose.
Remarkably, the Shy Guy had kept pace with
Thor almost the entire time the Asgardian
had been flying, smashing through every
tree and boulder that stood in its path.
Even so, Thor was more than ready for it.
Storm clouds rumbled overhead. The
sky above the mountain was trembling
as Thor decided that it was time to bring
down the thunder on his unfortunate foe.
Boom! Crack!
The heavens flashed with electrical might as
Thor channeled the energy from several lightning
bolts through mjollnir before unleashing
a consolidated blast of unbridled power
onto SCP-096. The Shy Guy didn’t even
attempt to dodge as Thor’s thundershock
treatment bombarded it with light and heat the
likes of which few mortals could withstand.
Thor released a second blast, then
a third, surrounding SCP-096 with as
much lightning as these earthly skies would
offer him. After keeping at this for a while,
Thor decided to let up momentarily to
check on his foe, only to see that there
were no signs of visible damage on the
creature. It wasn’t even slightly singed.
The God of Thunder could feel his brother
laughing at him from somewhere out of sight
and out of reach. The monstrous humanoid in
the forest below was proving to be far more
than Thor had bargained for, but he was nowhere
near ready to give in and accept defeat. Still,
maybe this wasn’t a fight worth having
on Earth. All Thor’s electrical attacks
were doing was destroying trees, and the
planet was already facing unprecedented
levels of deforestation due to the greed
of human CEOs and shady entrepreneurs.
Thor certainly didn’t want to be part of the
problem, and now that it was occurring to him,
he realized that he should probably try to do
something about that once this situation with
The Shy Guy was resolved. It didn’t matter how
close of a friend Elon Musk was to Tony Stark,
these overreaching humans had to be given
a stern talking to by The God of Thunder:
with or without a hammer in his hand.
Of course, Thor’s environmentalist
concerns had to go on the backburner
for now since SCP-096 was advancing towards
him once again with no hint of slowing down.
Let’s see if you can follow me back to
Asgard, you son of an elf. Thor thought.
He held his hammer aloft and counted on Heimdall
to deploy the bifrost. The rainbow bridge arrived
seconds before SCP-096’s arms would have reached
the Asgardian, and as expected, it instantly
carried Thor into the interdimensional space
between his destinations. Amidst the swirling
sea of multicolored lights, Thor shared a
laugh with nobody but himself and Mjollnir.
“So much for Shy Guy!” said Thor. “Looks like
it’ll have to resolve those body image issues on
its own time. I’ve been through something similar,
so I can relate. Best of luck, pitiful beast!”
But while Thor was congratulating himself for
his strategic retreat, he almost didn’t notice
that his foe hadn’t actually stopped
in its pursuit. As a matter of fact,
SCP-096 was currently inside of the Bifrost and
swiftly gaining on The God of Thunder. The Shy
Guy was truly running in the 90s. Well, 90 miles
per hour or more, but it made the same difference.
The creature grabbed Thor by his ankles and
screeched in mortified rage. Thor punched
SCP-096 in the face, hoping to shake it off
but to no avail. The two opponents spun through
the bifrost locked together in an unbreakable
grapple until they collided with the walls of the
interdimensional space. Thor knew exactly where
this was going, and he wasn’t happy about it.
Like a sheet of ice composed of photons, the outer
limits of the bifrost broke away, sending both
combatants shooting off into the void. Seconds
later, a wormhole spit Thor and SCP-096 out in
a vast junkyard filled with the remains of
countless spaceships and alien lifeforms.
Great. I’m trapped in this garbage world again.
I knew I should have picked somewhere closer.
Thor shook off the nauseating effects
of the failed interdimensional trip,
SCP-096 was already hale and hearty for another
round. Thor grimaced with frustrated anticipation.
“How about a quick five-minute rest?” Thor
implored The Shy Guy. “Gentleman’s truce?”
SCP-096 roared and dashed forth, more
crazed than ever. Thor exhaled in futility.
“I thought not.”
He whipped Mjollnir around and hurled it
straight for SCP-096’s skull. The reliable
uru-steal hammer made contact, knocking the
creature onto its back. At the very least,
Thor could always count on his signature
weapon to help him out. Or could he…?
When the Asgardian tried to call the
hammer back, he was shocked to find
that SCP-096 had somehow grabbed ahold
of its handle. Even more surprisingly,
it now appeared to be wielding the
hammer as easily as Thor could.
Son of a… You’re telling me that thing is worthy?
The Shy Guy, now with Mjollnir in hand, pounced
on Thor, swinging the hammer with no technique
or finesse. It was everything Thor could do
to simply avoid the creature’s range. A blow
from Mjollnir was enough to cause serious injury
to even the most formidable Asgardian warrior.
“Damn you, Mjollnir! We talked about this!”
Thor thundered. “We’re friends, aren’t we?”
But none of his words could get through to the
hammer now that it was in the hand of SCP-096.
In an act of righteous defiance, Thor
called the fury of lightning into his
own body. This strange foe which had come
from Loki’s latest prank was about to find
out what happened when a God of Thunder got
serious. With the speed of a lightning bolt,
Thor flew at SCP-096 and punched it so
hard that its grip loosened on Mjollnir
for all but a second. And that second was
all Thor needed to reclaim his weapon.
His hand clung tightly to Mjollnir’s handle
as he swung the weapon into the Shy Guy’s
body with all his might. The shockwave of this
forceful blow launched piles of debris high into
the air and sent SCP-096 tumbling across
the surface of the planet like a thrown
piece of discarded food at an Asgardian
feast. With another pulse of electricity,
Thor magnetized the portions of the rubble
which contained spaceship parts and used his
manipulation of that same energy to bury the Shy
Guy in the deepest heap of trash he could manage.
And with one last flick of Mjollnir, Thor sent
himself hurtling through the largest wormhole in
the sky above and back into space where it would
be far more difficult for his foe to follow him.
Finally, with some distance,
Thor breathed with relief.
You almost had me that time, Loki. What
an unusual being. Fought like a berserker,
but was somehow also pure of
heart. A kindred spirit to myself,
perhaps? Even so, I truly hope
to never meet that thing again.
Everyone in the sleepy mountain town had heard
stories about the abandoned mall, and the
malevolent creature that lurked in the wreckage
there.
There had been enough missing persons cases,
lost children, teenagers sneaking out to explore
and never returning home, urban explorers
who stumbled out of the darkness disheveled
and traumatized, with an eyewitness account
no one wanted to believe.
There wasn't anyone left in the surrounding
area willing to set foot in that cursed place.
But that didn't stop opportunistic out-of-towners
from paying the occasional visit.
Especially if they felt like there was money
to be made in those crumbling corporate walls.
Grant and Jason, the hosts of up-and-coming
investigative reality show "Ghostly Happenings,"
were two such visitors.
When they heard the rumors about an abandoned
mall haunted by some sort of dark presence
blamed for the disappearance of local children,
they packed up their van, picked up their
underpaid cameraman Derek, and headed straight
for the infamous building.
"Are you sure we're allowed to be here?"
Derek asked shakily as he began filming.
"Nope!"
Grant answered cheerfully.
"It's part of the fun," Jason laughed.
"Look man, this place has been left to rot
by the city.
No one cares if we're shooting some footage.
Besides, worry less about the cops and more
about...the ghost of the mall."
Grant grinned.
"OooooOOooOooo."
"Not funny," Derek grumbled.
"Come on, serious faces on!
We're rolling."
Jason nudged his cohost, and the two snapped
into their on-camera personalities.
"Once a bustling center of suburban American
life, this shopping mall has transformed into
a den of terror."
Grant's voice dropped into a lower register,
his expression intense.
"Locals swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home.
Something that doesn't take
kindly to trespassers,"
Jason added.
"A ghost?
A demon?
Just an urban legend?
That's what we're here to find out."
Grant pulled out an EMF reader, which began
beeping as he turned it on.
"There seems to be a lot of activity in here
already, I'm picking up something."
"Don't know if you folks at home can see this,
but the meter's going crazy!"
Jason exclaimed.
It was a fake meter, of course, one they'd
rigged up to beep and react when Grant pressed
certain hidden buttons.
But the audience didn't need to know that.
They were tuning in for story, for spectacle,
not for the truth.
If they wanted that, they could flip over
to the nature channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle.
On this show, they were
chasing pure entertainment.
They continued deeper into the building, taking
in the massive, echoey
space, the dusty storefronts,
the beams of rotten wood strewn across the
ground, the rats that skittered across the
floor.
It was the perfect creepy atmosphere.
Maybe a little too perfect, a little too creepy.
"What was that?!"
Derek practically jumped out of his skin,
spinning around to look at something behind
him.
"Hey, stay on us!"
Grant snapped.
"I saw something moving back there," Derek
insisted.
"It was a rat."
Jason rolled his eyes.
"There are tons of them in here."
Derek shook his head.
"No, it wasn't a rat.
It was way too big."
"Okay, a raccoon then.
Come on, get it together.
We've been way worse locations than this.
Remember the old tuberculosis hospital?"
Grant shuddered.
"Now that was scary.
This is nothing."
"Well, not nothing."
Jason elbowed his partner.
"I did a good job scouting this place, right?"
Grant was about to answer, when his foot bumped
something on the ground.
He looked down, and saw a polaroid camera
next to a long-empty water bottle, and a small
backpack.
"Oh man, get a shot of this!"
Derek obliged, while Jason took a closer look.
"This must've belonged to one of the urban
explorer types who came in here."
He unzipped the backpack, rummaging around.
"Hey, look!
Photos, tons of them."
He dumped the pictures out onto the ground.
"Think he got some spirit photography done
before he bit the dust?"
"Might as well see..."
Grant joined Jason on the ground, sifting
through the photos as Derek watched anxiously.
"Boring, boring, deer, dog, sunset- now wait
a minute..."
He stopped, holding up one specific polaroid.
"This is the money shot right here.
Derek, zoom in on this."
All three men looked at the picture, illuminated
by the camera's light.
It showed a tall, long-limbed, pale creature,
vaguely humanoid in shape but at the same
time distinctly not quite human.
Its mouth was stretched wide in a wordless
screech, its eyes bloodshot and wild.
Its long, tapered fingers were reaching toward
the camera.
"Damn, that's spooky," Jason laughed, a bit
of nervousness creeping into his voice.
"How do you think he set this up?"
Grant asked.
"What if it's real?"
Derek swallowed the lump in his throat.
"Don't be an idiot."
Grant scoffed.
But then, from outside, not one hundred feet
away, they heard a scream.
Ear-splittingly loud, filled with rage, pain,
and animalistic instinct.
It was like nothing any of them had ever heard
before.
The scream was followed by the sound of splitting
wood, branches crashing to the ground, and,
horrifyingly, the sound of something breaking
down a nearby wall.
"What did you do?!"
Jason backed away from the sound.
"Me?!
You opened the backpack!"
Grant shot back.
"Guys???
I think we need to get out of here!"
Derek watched in wide-eyed terror as two pale
hands ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them, making an opening for that pale, hairless
head from the photograph to poke through.
All three men prepared to make a break for
it and run for their lives, but as soon as
the creature saw them, it was already too
late.
With another scream, SCP-096 sprinted toward
them, grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground.
The camera shattered into pieces from the
impact, and Derek skidded painfully across
the ground.
As he rolled onto his side to try and push
back up to his feet, he caught a glimpse of
the monster opening its mouth impossibly wide,
and descending on his bosses.
He really didn’t want to focus on what happened
next, but suffice to say, there was nothing
of them left afterwards.
Derek tried his best to escape, but he was
no match for the brute strength and speed
of SCP-096.
From the moment he saw its face, his fate
was sealed.
There was no escape.
Soon, the beeping EMF meter, the scattered
photographs, and the broken pieces of the
camera were the only thing left of the crew
from "Ghostly Happenings."
Their devoted fans would never get another
episode.
But at least one being in the abandoned mall
could rest easy now.
SCP-096 was safe again, no one was living
who had seen its face.
It slowly crawled back to the hole it had
made in the wall, ready to return to the forest
and climb back up the mountain.
There, it could curl up beneath a tree and
stay there for as long as it wanted.
But as SCP-096 reached the hole in the wall,
where it had once been able to see night sky,
stars, and the trees in the distance, there
was only blackness.
It was as if something dark was stretched
over the opening, blocking the outside world
from view.
096 reached out a hand to push the blockage
out of the way, but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale hand
could move.
The wriggling darkness crept back into the
building, weaving in and out of the shadows
as SCP-096 watched it, curiously.
Whatever it was, it hadn't
looked at the creature's
face yet...it wasn't sure if the thing even
had eyes.
But then, stretching out of the darkness and
into view was a garish face, wide white eyes
with massive pupils, a round nose, and a wide,
wide mouth stretched into a toothy grimace
that might have once looked like a smile.
This was the creature that had made the mall
its home, the apex predator of this biosphere,
and it was staring directly at SCP-096's face.
Its FACE!
With a shriek, SCP-096 flew into a primal
rage, clawing at the catlike creature, but
before 096 could reach it, the thing was gone.
Where was it?
Where did it go? 096 roared, tearing at the
floor, ripping up the tile and gouging long,
deep scratches in the concrete beneath.
A sound in the distance drew 096's attention,
and it bolted in the direction of the noise,
swinging at any obstacle in its path as it
went.
It ripped down a banner advertising free frozen
yogurt samples, crushed an empty cell phone
kiosk, and threw a gumball machine to the
floor with a crash.
It would rip the entire mall apart if it had
to, if that was what it took to destroy the
being that had caught a glimpse of its face
and disappeared.
Then, 096 could see it.
That face, that wide-eyed, grinning face.
It sprinted toward the face as fast as it
could.
The Cartoon Cat was looking at 096, not from
a place in the room, but from behind the screen
of a television in the electronics store window.
Somehow, defying the laws of physics and reality,
it had made its way into the tv.
SCP-096 didn't pause to ponder the logic of
this.
There was no room for critical thought.
There was only the need to shred, to consume,
to destroy.
It burst through the window, sending shards
of glass in every direction, and reared back
to attack the screen.
It was so focused on its singular task that
it didn't notice the long black arms snaking
across the floor, winding around its feet.
All of a sudden, 096 lost its balance as its
legs were pulled right out from under it,
those stretchy arms dragging it into the tv
screen itself.
When 096 regained consciousness, it was in
a place it did not recognize.
Gone was the inside of the mall, or the familiar
forest and mountains outside.
Instead, SCP-096 was in some sort of hand-drawn
world, a massive house with a hallway that
seemed to go on forever, lined with infinite
doors leading to who knew where.
The floor tipped and tilted at odd angles,
and the geometry made no three-dimensional
sense.
It was dizzying, and deeply off-putting.
SCP-096 had no frame of reference to compare
it to, but a human witness might have noticed
that this place looked like something out
of an old cartoon, from the days of Steamboat
Willy and the like.
SCP-096 did not think such a thing.
It only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
place, one that felt threatening, though there
were no visible threats.
And it knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its face.
All along the walls, between each door, there
were clocks in the shape of that horrible
cat, eyes ticking back and forth with each
second, wide smile mocking SCP-096, as if
to say, "try and find me."
SCP-096 would not be discouraged.
There was no room in its mind for that sort
of thing.
There was only the singular goal of finding
the Cartoon Cat and tearing it limb from rubber
hose limb.
Psychological warfare would have no effect.
Still, Cartoon Cat would give it his best
shot.
This was his world, and he could do whatever
he wanted here.
Cartoon Cat poked his head out through a random
doorway, waving to 096 with one of his puffy
white gloved hands.
As 096 wailed and began to gave chase, Cartoon
Cat slammed the door shut, only to open another
door down the hall and poke his head out of
that one.
He did the same trick over and over, jerking
SCP-096 around from end to
end of the ever-expanding
animated hallway.
After some time passed, however, it appeared
SCP-096 was not going to get tired, and was
not going to give up hope of catching its
prey.
It was time to end this.
Cartoon Cat wrapped one long arm around SCP-096's
neck, restraining it against the wall, and
began to squeeze tighter and tighter.
But nothing happened.
096 did not collapse, did not react at all
except to tear at the arm around its neck
until it broke free.
Then, it returned to its relentless pursuit,
tearing doorframes apart, pulling up floorboards,
punching through walls.
Every time it dealt damage to the environment,
the space filled itself back in, an unseen
pen scribbling in the gaps in the floorboards,
sealing up the holes in the walls.
Two powerful beings going back and forth,
locked in a seemingly equally-matched battle.
Cartoon Cat tried to destroy SCP-096 in myriad
ways.
He tried to rip the beast apart, to snap its
neck, to do any manner of unspeakable violent
acts that it had done before, with great sadistic
glee.
But this pale abomination would not fold,
would not break.
This wasn't going to be any fun if there was
no ending, and if 096 kept destroying one
of Cartoon Cat's favorite pocket worlds.
That was quite enough.
Cartoon Cat grabbed hold of 096's arms and
legs, the creature thrashing viciously as
he did so, and threw it into the blank space
just beyond the illustrated world.
Back in the mall, SCP-096 crashed back to
earth.
It was about to resume its search for Cartoon
Cat, when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face.
A police officer stood a few feet away, holding
a flashlight.
"Scuse me, you can't be in here.
You're trespassing."
The officer started to warn, but his words
were interrupted when SCP-096 began to scream.
Soon, he would be screaming too.
That’s right. It’s time once again to
activate the famed Anom-O-Tron 600,
our patented machine that definitely
wasn’t developed in affiliation with
Doctor Wondertainment. We swear. After
recalibrating, rebooting, and hitting restart,
our infamous specialized supercomputer is
ready to bring you all manner of improbable
scenarios. We’ll simulate encounters between
the SCP Foundation’s various anomalies,
and any other character from any other
universe you could possibly imagine.
Here’s a question for you: what do you think
would happen if SCP-096, the notorious Shy Guy,
ran afoul of someone he couldn’t just kill
for daring to look at it? What if the scourge
of the underworld, battler of demons, and the
Devil himself, set his sights on SCP-096? Well,
we’re about to hit the button and discover the
outcome of SCP-096 vs The dreaded Doom Slayer!
So, you’ve heard the old philosophical debate
about a tree falling down in the woods,
and whether or not nobody being around to
hear it brings into question if it actually
happened at all, right? Well, let’s reframe
that one a little. If an interdimensional rip
in the very fabric of the time-space continuum
opens up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it, does a
six-foot-tall, three-hundred-and-sixty-pound
hulking killing machine still emerge
to slaughter everything in his path?
It turns out, yes; yes, he definitely does.
Horrified screams and the loud bang of shotgun
blasts rang out through the hallways as Foundation
researchers ran for their lives. The Doom Marine
had just been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar environment.
Mere minutes earlier, he had been awakened
inside a sarcophagus within a facility on Mars,
in the year 2148. Unfortunately, Doomguy
hadn’t had the best start to his day given
that the base he’d woken up in was being
overrun by the forces of Hell itself,
thanks to a rogue scientist opening up portals
to the underworld and allowing all manner of
demonic abominations to come pouring through.
So, naturally, when another portal brought the
armor-clad demon slayer to a site run by the SCP
Foundation, the intensity of battle had led to
the Doom Slayer believing the unsuspecting staff
were actually all demons in disguise. And to him,
the only good demon is one he got to send back
to hell in the most brutal fashion imaginable.
He wasn’t going to stop until he’d torn through
wave after wave of Foundation personnel, thinking
perhaps if he killed enough, he’d be returned
to his previous locale for more demon killing.
As the Foundation dispatched its security
forces and Mobile Task Forces to take down
the unstoppable force of carnage decked out in
head-to-toe green armor, it seemed nothing they
could throw at the Doom Marine was enough to
take him down. A hail of bullets rained down
on him from the MTFs’ weapons, ricocheting
ineffectually off his protective plating as
he continued his assault, remaining tireless
thanks to his immense physical conditioning.
The SCP Foundation tried and failed to contain
Doomguy. They had assumed him to be either a new,
undocumented anomaly or a violent and unhinged
maniac from the Church of the Broken God, given
his armor resembling cybernetic augmentations and
machine parts grafted to his body, along with his
arsenal of advanced weaponry. But there were
no enhancements, no augmentations made to the
Doom Slayer; he may have once been mortal,
but centuries of killing demons had allowed
him to transcend ordinary human physiology. He
didn’t tire, never lost strength, never needed
to eat or drink, and was near enough immortal.
Yet, among all the chaos that was unfurling,
a solitary researcher had just managed to slip
out of the Doom Slayer’s reach. He ran as fast
and far as he was physically able; the Mobile
Task Force troops were getting eviscerated,
the Slayer could easily tear through the
whole Foundation. Then, fleeing for his life,
the researcher had an idea: either a stroke of
genius or total idiocy, and a risky move either
way. He’d set an anomaly on the Doom Slayer.
He turned to the nearest containment cell,
a windowless room with a heavy, locked door.
Hurriedly inputting his security clearance code,
the researcher heaved the door open and
covered his eyes with his arm. It wouldn’t
have been his first choice of SCP to send into
battle, but SCP-096’s cell was the closest.
Lumbering out of its containment chamber on its
misshapen, elongated legs, SCP-096 scanned the
area. Alarms were blaring, it was loud and
frightening to the timid, albeit terrifying
creature, that reached up to cover its ears in
bewilderment. Not that the researcher who had
freed it could see what it was doing. For one,
his eyes were still covered. And for another,
he was already dead, thanks to the Doom Slayer
barging shoulder-first through a nearby wall and
raining debris on the nearby researcher.
Beneath the visor of his helmet,
the Marine breathed heavily, panting
but not tiring as he looked at the pale,
skinny creature in the corridor before him.
It was clutching the sides of its head;
its huge jaw hung open. As far the Slayer knew,
he was making progress; his attack was working.
He’d killed enough of these demonic imposters
that they were starting to reveal their true
forms. Although, in all his years of bloodshed
and being a scourge to the denizens of Hell,
he hadn’t quite ever seen a demon that looked
like the Shy Guy. Not that it mattered to Doomguy,
before long, it’d be dead like all the rest.
The towering, stick-thin creature turned
to face the armor-adorned warrior and
shrieked, immediately overcome with anguish,
having a full-blown breakdown as it often did
whenever someone looked at it. As the demon
killer stomped down the corridor towards it,
The Doomblade, a long, sleek razor sharp edge
extended from the Slayer’s gauntlet where
it was mounted on his wrist. He reached
down and yanked the rip cord on his chainsaw
too – he was long overdue for a glory kill.
But before he could strike at SCP-096,
the Shy Guy moved with impossible speed,
faster than even the Doom Marine himself. It
zipped behind the encroaching Marine, moving
quicker than he could perceive: one second
SCP-096 was crying and wailing in front of him,
then not even a full second later the creature
was towering over Doomguy from behind.
SCP-096 gripped the Doomblade and snapped it with
ease, like breaking a twig before reaching its
other long arm down and pulling the chainsaw
from Doomguy’s hand. The motorized blade was
still running as it clattered to the ground,
cutting a hole through the floor and falling
down into the lower level of the facility.
Enraged, as he very often was, the Doom Slayer
reached both arms back behind his head and gripped
the elongated torso of SCP-096. The virtually
immortal killing machine hurled the creature
over his head with ease; thanks to his immense
strength, Doomguy could lift objects far heavier
than most ordinary humans, and carry heavy weapons
without tiring. He had even grappled hand-to-hand
with demons. Throwing the Shy Guy down the
corridor like hurling a basketball was no trouble
for the spacefaring slaughterer of Satan’s spawn.
Screaming and howling in pain, SCP-096 crashed
to the ground at the far end of the corridor,
tumbling over itself thanks to its long limbs
before landing in a confused heap. As the Shy
Guy reoriented itself, struggling back onto
its feet and standing up at its full height,
it was instantly knocked back as
the force of something struck it.
Baring down on SCP-096, the Doom Marine charged,
his signature double-barrelled, sawed-off shotgun
drawn. It was hardly leaving a scratch on
SCP-096’s pale skin, despite the moderate
amount of damage the weapon was capable of. Two
shots would ring out, reeling the creature but
not harming it. Then, by the time SCP-096 managed
to recover from the blast, the Slayer had finished
reloading in time to open fire yet again. Even as
the Doom Slayer raced nearer, closing the distance
between him and what he thought to be another
demon for him to kill, the shotgun seemed to have
little effect against the Shy guy at close range.
Stowing the weapon, Doomguy put all of his focus
and energy into his charge, heavy boots stomping
against the ground as he raced towards the Shy
guy, still stunned by the last shotgun blast.
Before the creature could steady itself,
this time it was struck by another force,
a heavy object barrelling towards it. The
Doom Slayer shoulder barged SCP-096, sending the
pair of them crashing through the nearest wall.
They burst into a neighboring room, with the Doom
Slayer keeping a single-armed grip around the Shy
Guy while repeatedly delivering vicious punches to
its gut with his other hand, not once relenting.
SCP-096 screeched in pain, clawing at the Slayer
but unable to tear through his impenetrable armor.
As they crashed through yet another wall, SCP-096
did something it rarely ever did. In fact, maybe
something it had never ever done before. It ran
away from someone that had looked at it. While the
creature was deeply insecure and so self-conscious
that it would kill anyone who saw so much as a
photograph of it, it didn’t often feel afraid.
But the Doom Slayer, this muscle-bound killing
machine that had brutally butchered actual demons
was so imposing, so threatening, and so effective
at dispensing painful punishment, that he scared
the fight out of SCP-096. Sobbing with terror, the
creature zipped away using its anomalous speed,
trying desperately to put as much distance between
it and the Doom Marine as it possibly could.
But therein lay the problem. No sooner had
SCP-096 gotten away from the Scourge of Hell, then
the creature immediately felt the familiar pull.
Whether it was an inescapable compulsion to kill
everyone who looked at it, or a fact of the Shy
Guy’s biology, it could only distance itself from
the Slayer for a few seconds before it reappeared
near him. From Doomguy’s perspective, it seemed
the creature was intentionally disappearing and
reappearing using its teleportation-like
speed to evade a volley of his attacks.
SCP-096 came at him again, stuck in a loop of
trying to attack the Doom Slayer for looking
at it, to immediately regretting that course
of action and fleeing in fear of its hulking,
heavy weapon-toting target. Doomguy
drew every weapon he had in his arsenal,
launching a barrage of high explosive ordinance
from his rocket launcher to try and kill SCP-096.
The resultant damage practically reduced an
entire wing of the Foundation site to rubble,
but still couldn’t kill the Slayer’s opponent.
Meanwhile, in the moments that the Shy Guy
temporarily forgot his own fear for the Doomguy,
it managed to rush towards him, swiping the
Marine’s various technologically advanced
armaments out of his hands before instantly
remembering why he was so scared of the green
armored force of destruction and dashing away.
Doomguy’s supply of weapons had all but
been depleted, neither he nor SCP-096
were getting tired out by their constant back
and forth. They were locked in a stalemate,
until the Shy Guy tried to get back to its cell.
Zipping away once again, it cowered in the corner,
reaching for an old, worn-out paper bag that it
slipped over its head. It sat down, trembling,
rocking back and forth in a fetal position.
The Shy Guy was terrified, an overwhelming,
debilitating fear gripped it… fear that
became pure dread as the sound of heavy
boots began to stomp closer and closer.
Kicking the steel door off its hinges,
the Doom Slayer walked into SCP-096’s cell,
carrying something huge in his hands. It was
one of the most devastating weapons Doomguy had
at his disposal, capable of unleashing untold
destruction: the BFG 9000. Without remorse, not
caring that the creature seemed to have retreated
and was cowering away from him, the Slayer raised
the powerful weapon and fired an enormous ball of
green energy. The blast engulfed the entire room,
tendrils snaking out from the energy projectile
causing additional damage to the surrounding
area until… there was nothing left of SCP-096…